man it's been a it's been a terrible
week for me I woke up this morning like
I'm gonna work again my voice is getting
better and it was worse and I'm like how
is it worse so it's it's working now I
think maybe by tomorrow morning it'll
probably be okay but I started recording
my first segment and I was getting angry
because I'm like I will not take another
day off I hate taking days off and then
after like four minutes I literally
couldn't talk I'm like yo this is this
is BS man when you said hate you sounded
like Cobra Commander
I thought of Scrooge for a second
yeah amen uh anyway did as you were
getting angry or were you screaming
louder and shredding your voice more I
was I was trying to get louder to push
through and then I stopped and I'm just
like if I'm gonna get my voice better I
can't do it I have to stop I have to
just go hang out and play OverWatch or
something and I was pissed off the whole
day just like sitting there like angrily
running around at Sombra just killing
people from behind Sombra so not diva
no no because Sombra goes uh stealth and
then you can run behind somebody
and then I was just I like playing
Bastion because uh you know he's got
whatever it's called they do with the
big shield no the artillery I'm a big
fan of you mowing everybody down and I'm
like I feel good playing video anyway
ladies and gentlemen uh it was one of my
favorite subjects in the world Stephen
Crowder put out a video called it's time
to stop where he calls out the big con
in conservative media and uh I commented
on his video saying Stephen Crowder is
right about everything I want to provide
context as to what I meant by that
because he's right about everything in
terms of how these companies function
how the contracts work but I don't think
the bigger picture
like I don't think Stephen Crowder
commented on the bigger picture that's
why you know I'm not going to say he's
wrong but I think there's a lot to
understand and how these contracts work
and what the future has to hold so this
is going to be a whole lot of fun I'm
basically going to spill the beans on
like basically everything to the extent
that I can I know a lot of these guys I
know the CEOs of all these companies
I've talked with all of them about more
than than these things so I'm I respect
their privacy I'm not going to reveal
any confidential details that could harm
anybody in any way but I'll tell you
about everything I can personally and
how it's affected us and uh Stephen
Crowder calling out how this machine is
working for those that are familiar with
the context basically Crowder left the
Blaze and has been working on his own
his own thing I suppose and obviously it
looks like he's been shopping around
he posted details of a contract he
received calling out what he calls the
big con so we're going to talk about the
media landscape how everybody's
responding to it but we've got a bunch
of other news too hey you know we got uh
Davos is happening and a whole bunch of
hookers are flying in and so I just
think that's a funny story to talk about
because they want to ban hookers for you
but they get all the hookers in the
world so we'll talk about that plus I
mean to get serious we got a crazy story
there's apparently some failed GOP
candidate who orchestrated allegedly
shootings targeting Democrats apparently
what was it Luke he tried he brought a
fully automated machine gun that
malfunctioned in one of the houses yes
that's crazy man all right seriously
let's get into before we get started
head over to timcast.com become a member
to support our work we uh full
disclosure man
we we exist because of memberships
Crowder brought this up in his video
he's completely right I saw the writing
on the wall he saw the writing on the
wall and so this is why everybody's
creating subscription Services because
for us to keep producing content we rely
on knowing how much money is coming out
every month to pay salaries and uh that
means we're I remember a couple years
ago I was like okay just doing ads on
YouTube is extremely dangerous because
ads stopped when covet happened like
gone and I'm like well our money's gone
how do I even make a video I just got to
cross my fingers and push through and
then I'm like well you need to do a
website we do a website with members
only we create exclusive stuff for those
members as something they can buy and
then we know for sure with like a
drop-off margin how much money we will
have per month and if we can keep doing
this and we're growing and that's why we
have the the members only over at
timcast.com so become a member it really
does make sure the machine works and
then obviously ad revenue is the icing
is the icing on top and as a member what
you're investing in our cultural
endeavors this is going to be a big show
because we'll talk about I'm gonna talk
about Stephen Crowder and I'll talk
about what we're investing money in why
crowd Crowder encountered this contract
that he did why these big companies
offer these things and I think it's
going to be enlightening for everybody
as I explain how things work here my
motivations my risks my losses and I
think y'all are in for a really really
interesting show so grab some popcorn
because I'm going to talk hard numbers
you're gonna have fun with this one
smash the like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
I hope you like my fancy glasses joining
us to talk about this and so much more
we got the crew from the tower gang
what's up brother uh Clint Russell I'm
the host of liberty lockdown highly
acclaimed and the highly insane Tower
gang with my brother top Lobster as well
as read Coverdale toad fat Dave named
after Dave Smith which I know everyone
here is a fan of and uh who do I miss oh
Jose Galla's son as well yeah it's crazy
this is the greatest graphic designer on
Earth Mr top Lobster yeah I'm uh I go by
top Lobster I own toplopsa.com it's a
merchandising company
um I'm the graphic designer for uh break
the cycle with Joshua Smith the vice
chair of the lp I also uh owned part of
uh podcastmarts.com which is uh that's a
company that we do merch for uh a gas
digital podcast like uh Dave Smith's
part of the problem
um Michael malice is still on there
Legion of skanks things like that so
that's really what I'm focused on and
thanks for having me here guys
hell yeah hey guys I'm gonna be leaving
this week but not today uh and I wanted
to remind you guys about
bidenfetterman.com it's an actual
website it is my website we talked about
this yesterday and that's why I'm
wearing my Biden fetterman 2024 shirt
and to be specific here when I mean
Biden I mean hunter Biden it's the
leadership that we deserve let the ship
sink already let's get it over with you
could get the shirt on
bidenfetterman.com see you there Luke
what you understand is when the ship
sinks it's just a submarine man that's
gonna keep going it never stops uh we're
better off taking control at the helm
right now than letting it fall apart
um hey I wanted to point out we did an
episode of liberty lockdown last year I
guess was last year almost a while ago
it was a good time yeah it was great I
also did an episode with Jose who's not
here tonight represent what's up Jose
and uh
um no way Jose yeah that's very good
that was a good time Ian Crossland here
happy to be here high energy surge
let's go yeah we're talking about this
before the Pod that uh yeah everyone
thinks I'm like super chill and I'm like
no energy that's the joke though
as soon as the show's over
there he goes crazy you get your picture
hey I'm at search.com everywhere uh it's
been fun I've been uh posting on Twitter
trying to figure this machine out a
little bar but uh I'm excited to get
into this it's gonna be a good episode
Tim seems ready to go let's get it I
grabbed the cough drop let's see if that
works all right everybody our first
story from our good friends over at
Media Matters who I thought you know
it's the perfect website to use when
talking about the big con and Stephen
Crowder
mediamatters.org says Stephen Crowder
lashes out at big con of conservative
media for allegedly colluding with tech
companies like YouTube quote those in
charge the big conservative the big con
and it really is the biggest con going
right now they're making it known in
their contracts that they will enforce
the guidelines of big Tech and punish
conservatives on their behalf
Stephen Crowder one of the most
prominent if not the most prominent
prominent I guess what would you
describe this conservative media
movement or or anti-establishment
movement one of the most prominent
voices if not the most prominent put out
a video today
just straight up calling out big
conservative media and I commented on
the video I said he's right about
everything but I want to clarify what I
mean by that because maybe maybe it's a
little inappropriate he's right about
the contracts he's right about the
machine he's right about how this whole
system works but there's an
understanding you need to have the
machine itself is the these contracts
it's the product of
how the law is structured how the market
is structured and it's an inevitability
the only way it changes when people like
Stephen Crowder don't sign these deals
people like any of you who are signing
up don't sign these deals
say no to these deals and build a
completely new system and that means
we've got big challenges it means that
Disney's got an advantage you want to
know why Disney's got an advantage
because when when Stephen Crowder
he leaves The Blaze
he's obviously shopping around that's
why he's got this contract he says these
terms are insane
he doesn't need to sign it many people
do need to sign these deals and they do
sign these deals for a company like
Disney I remember I got a contract from
them I signed it it was a lot of cash a
lot of cash I didn't have and I said
okay
and then within the confines of that
contract I eventually was like I know
what I have to do and I know what I'm
not going to do and you're not going to
get me to do anything please break my
contract they said no I got locked up
for a couple years they call that golden
handcuffs it is extremely common in the
media industry
I think Jack Huger talked about it when
he was at MSNBC yep same thing happened
to Jesse Ventura when he was critical of
the war in Iraq they silenced him and
essentially got rid of his show that
they paid a lot of money for and he
essentially a year was just sitting and
couldn't do any interviews or his own
show which is absolutely so let's let's
do this I'll I'll start off by saying um
Stephen Crowder launching his own thing
is the most important thing he can do
but that the the current reality of big
media especially with an
anti-establishment landscape is that
these deals are quite literally
impossible and more importantly
they're impossible for someone like
Stephen Crowder
so I'll say this to get started and then
you're gonna have to ask me questions I
guess on what you're thinking Crowder's
too big there's no way anyone can sign a
deal with Stephen Crowder uh it's just
that simple dude's got nearly 6 million
subscribers how do you do a deal with
this man he owns the space so imagine
you're we've got a handful of companies
uh obviously everybody's giving their
thoughts on which company they think
this wasn't offered them a contract but
there's a lot right obviously there was
the blaze I know we know rumble's doing
it a lot of deals with people the daily
wires obviously another big one they've
got a big roster what are some other
companies in in the space are there any
beautiful Wars Infowars obviously I
doubt I doubt Infowars uh I don't know
if Stephen will go to Infowars though
Ohan no no I mean Newsmax uh given the
legal troubles crowd probably not
honestly fox fox is there yeah
absolutely Fox they're looking for a
comedian to host I heard well well
um
they got Gutfeld he's he's slain it yeah
Alex Jones and Steve and Stephen Crowder
did multiple interviews and Alex Jones
even said that he's moving away from his
kind of libertarian policies and
agreeing with Stephen when it comes to
more kind of status Solutions it's
possible it's completely possible so
everybody has their speculation crtv is
also another big one crtv is the blaze
oh God yeah and and turning points are
maybe but I think Fox is probably a
really good guest too like people got it
people gotta understand
whoever this company is like I would
tell you fox probably has the worst
terms you guys want to play some games
Fox guests aren't allowed on this show
actually
I don't know about contractually I just
know that probably pissing off Fox right
now yeah like we we routinely have
people say stuff like I wish I'm a big
fan we love the show we'd love to come
on too bad we can't by the way Fox
whoever you guys have your people come
on because it would be phenomenal for
all of us is it this show specifically
or just any podcast form this show is
specifically blacklisted for Fox
personalities
um that doesn't make any sense to me oh
that makes absolute sense we compete
directly with Tucker Carlson yeah a lot
of people see a competition instead of
actually you know working together
cohesively there's also uh prageru epac
times there's a lot of media
organizations in the space that do have
the money that could facilitate this who
but but how do you do a deal with
Stephen Carr because let's break it down
let's let's break it down you got six
million subscribers on Stephen Crowder's
Channel let's say you create the Crowder
Club you know he's got mug Club but
let's say you're um I don't want to name
any company so let's make up a fake one
uh conservative Inc let's say you run
conservative Inc and you're like we got
some investor cash you know big wig
libertarian billionaire who bought a
bunch of Bitcoin because he's a creep
can afford to invest he's helping run
our company investing in our company we
can hire one of these guys how much can
we reasonably afford to spend let's
think about the revenues uh we'll use
the daily wire because they've talked
about their numbers what do they have
900 000 paying subscribers yeah is that
what it was yeah Matt Walsh really
brought in that money for them to be to
be honest so let's just look at their
their memberships they got a seven
dollar a 10 or 13 or something like that
so let's just go for the middle and say
it's like ten dollars per person they're
doing what nine million dollars in
membership Revenue per month they've
also got what seven big personalities
they've also got ad Revenue let me let
me let me do a quick math on what I pre
what I think their ad Revenue might be
well actually no I think they said well
didn't it say they were doing like 100
million a year or something like that I
don't remember I don't remember either
it was like 120. I'd be willing to bet
that uh they probably do
I don't know 15 is around it's a guess
15 million bucks per month sponsorship
Revenue only goes so far you can be
really really big but it only goes so
far so let's say it's the bulk as
memberships 15 million per month but you
got to pay for what do they have 300
employees
I don't know the numbers of daily wire
very well let's say top level Talent has
to be extraordinarily expensive Jordan
Peterson I mean oh yeah Jordan Peterson
I imagine they'd pay him like I was
going to mention that like 10 million
bucks in comparison to Stephen Crowder
where is where does Jordan Peterson fall
there Jordan Peterson's a very different
personality Stephen Crowder has
guaranteed numbers right when you when
when you when you're trying to sign
someone like Crowder you're like I can
look at how many people comment I can
look at how many people view each of
your videos and not only that
if he's got
um uh membership only content he can
provide those metrics as well and then
you can say I know how much money I can
make off this
but imagine you're uh you know I don't
even know how much money fox makes they
have like they have like cable contracts
which guarantees them probably like
you know hundreds of millions of dollars
per year yeah guaranteed just for being
on the cable networks because the cable
deals they're they that people sign up
for cable because they want Fox News
right
so Fox News how much my question is this
let's say conservative Inc contact
Stephen Crowder how much can they
reasonably afford to pay him how much
they can how much can they make off of
him and how do they make money off of
him let's take a look at this contract
in this video you can see this it says
merch rights blank will maintain the
exclusive right to create and sell
Crowder and Crowder content branded
merchandise all remuneration for the
blank and exploitation of these rights
is included in the fee
okay email list blank will maintain the
exclusive rights to manage grow and
monetize all crowd or email email lists
during the term all remuneration for the
exploitation of these rights is included
in the fee
social media management blank will have
the exclusive right to manage curate and
monetize Crowder's official Facebook
YouTube Apple podcast Spotify Snapchat
Rumble and other social media accounts
excluding Crowder's existing personal
Twitter and Instagram accounts during
the term additionally blank will have
the perpetual and exclusive right to
create own managed to curate and
monetize any and all social media
accounts on any social media or similar
platform as determined by blank on the
Crowder content or shows all
remuneration for the exploitation of
these rights is included in the fee
what's the fee
well Crowder offered 100 million dollars
because I got to tell you if someone
came to me and said look
we can make merch based on you ours we
can manage an email list everything
hours
we're going to handle all of our social
media content all of that will happen
only within the term as it states in the
contract what's the term typically three
years is what they'll try to get you on
whenever I was negotiating contracts
they'd always say three years and I'd
laugh and I'd say no and they but that's
standard I'm like I don't care what
standard we'll do two years and two
years is kind of I did two years of
fusion what's the fee
is Crowder mad that they offered him a
really garbage fee in exchange for
control of all of his all of his rights
and all of his production it's possible
I don't know don't know how much money
he was offered but I'll tell you this if
he was offered say 200 million dollars
over three years is that contract
unreasonable no if he was offered five
million dollars for three years then
it's unreasonable absolutely yeah so
that's a big question here this contract
may look exploitative but it's really we
don't know the consideration exactly if
I went to you and said
I will give you like if if I had a
contract and it said like you must turn
over your house immediately
you must give me all property you own
and then you went around showing people
like look at this contract it says he
can take everything from me people might
be like wow that's crazy and then he's
not showing you the page where it says
in exchange I give you my house and a
million dollars you know what I mean
it's like we don't know if the deal is
fair or not if you're gonna sell your
soul you better back up the Brinks truck
you know like it better be better be
heavy money because as you said Crowder
is making crazy money so he doesn't need
to sell his easy though well do you not
think so with Mud Club and all that who
owns my club he said he owns it he owns
it yeah he owns it now or he owned it
before I don't know in this video from
from what I saw I watched about 20
minutes of it he was saying that
basically we can do this on our own with
mug Club I can open up my own thing if I
if need be but he didn't really go into
specifics about how much he's making so
if he's going to open up his own thing
I'll tell you man
Crowder with 6 million subscribers when
he did the the coverage of the midterms
and he had what like half a million live
viewers
if I was gonna just spitball a number
that I think Crowder independent would
make it would be 10 million dollars per
month wow
the daily wire is Big the daily wire is
basically Ben Shapiro you've got Ben
Shapiro and then you go down the the
roster so it's like Matt Walsh now uh
maybe their biggest money maker
oh yeah what is a woman was was just
massive these are things they've stated
publicly right they've talked about how
they brought in like 300 000 new members
off that alone I think that's what they
said I don't know for sure it's just
what I heard and I mean you got to think
about that 300 000 new members on a
documentary that probably cost a couple
hundred grand to make a couple hundred
grand a market if you want to do it big
true then at Times Square billboard I
think they I think they had a running
yeah they knocked out of the park with
that so imagine you got 13 bucks a month
is the tier to watch video and you had
300 000 people
let's say the average person stays on as
a member the churn rate for every
company is different but let's say it's
a year
that's a lot of money to come in off one
documentary I need to ask you a question
because you've got a lot of more
experience with YouTube by the way twice
struck liberty lockdown please forgive
me my overlords I'm sorry I know not
what I've done
um but that's no joke your channel got
two strikes in the last what three weeks
ten days since I had James Lindsay on uh
he went down the same line of thinking
that he expressed on this fine program I
have no idea what I did wrong and they
will not tell me they won't give me a
timestamp it just it breaks my heart I'm
trying my best to stay on there I really
it's important that you guys are
listening to admins because Clint is you
actually mentioned you might not even be
putting videos on YouTube for like 90
days out of fear that you get a third
strike for unknown reasons I can't risk
it and that's not good so if you guys
can look at that and please I'm begging
um but the reason I wanted to ask Tim is
because he's got so much experience with
this are are you basically saying that
Google
because of the parent company of YouTube
is is so well ran in terms of paying
their their creators that you cannot
really compete in this space any any
longer what do you mean well it seems as
if you're you're implying that because
Crowder has such an enormous following
on YouTube and the revenue that he's
deriving from that okay go ahead no no
what I'm saying is that
the people who run let's let's let's
just let's just I don't want to name any
specific companies I don't call anybody
out sure
um a lot of people are like name names
name names I don't think there's bad
guys here if you are a businessman and
you're like how do we cultivate Talent
so look at the daily why for example
Michael Knowles Rose from inside the
daily wire what was he like he's an
editor or something I can't remember
what his job was yeah he was behind the
scenes they found Talent they cultivated
that talent and they found a rising star
so so here before the show we were
getting into it and I was like we got to
save it for the show let me tell you
something
we make a lot of money uh at timcast.com
I've never talked about our next our
membership numbers things like that
because
I don't know it's a private business
we're not a non-profit you know uh and I
don't I don't I think a lot of people
don't understand how expensive things
can be and money
um when it comes to you know doing
things like this but we do make a lot
and I love that you rake by the way we
do we do I love it I I I think we do
around uh eight figures per year that's
beautiful so this is and it's almost
exclusively just me personally
so we have employees who help run Tim
cast IRL where's the Bugatti yet where's
the private I have I have a Model S the
Bugatti's right here baby we've we've
flown private uh several times oh nice
man yeah so uh and I'll explain a lot of
this too like uh I'll just I'll just
I'll just break everything down for
everybody so you can understand how
exactly everything works I don't care
about fancy cars I don't care about big
houses I don't care about infinity pools
I care about literally none of it I
don't care about having a million
Bitcoin I don't care about uh you know
having a pet in New York City I care
about good people doing good things to
make things better because I don't like
bad things yeah and what do I see I
complain about it all day all the bad
things so let me explain how this
company Works we're very different from
big con and a lot of these companies
I wish I was the kind of guy who could
fire everybody shut the whole company
down and then just take all of that
money and put in my pocket because it is
almost entirely just me
if if
I I talk about this quite a bit
I told this to Stephen some days I think
back to when I was sitting in New Jersey
in front of my computer in my boxers
playing World of Warcraft I think I
can't remember which one is Legion I
think uncovered the void elves that was
fun uh are unlocked and I had like 180
000 subscribers on on youtube.comcast I
had a hundred thousand on timcast news
and I was making about 300 000 per year
just off that
and then Joe Rogan calls me up we have a
conversation then Joe Rogan invites me
out and I say this is awesome I should
totally do it sometimes I think back and
I'm like maybe I shouldn't have done it
maybe I'd like to I'd like to peer into
the crystal ball and find that timeline
where I said Joe with respect love your
work not interested have a nice day
because I'd be sitting there minding my
own business with no headaches with no
employees and I'd be making a ton of
money and then with that money I could
buy a bunch of gold bars put those gold
bars in my closet and then a year later
I look at my closet the gold bars are
sitting there so here's the thing about
these big media companies and why they
do these deals and why they offer the
contracts they do first I'll say it
again Crowder's right to say no to these
contracts he's right to say these
contracts are bad nobody should take
these deals it's a new world make your
own channel Forge your way it is
difficult but that's what has to be done
especially for someone as big as Crowder
I can certainly understand why there is
someone thinking like yeah but if I get
a job at the daily wire I could be the
next Michael knows total fact total fact
here's the thing
what do we what do we do the majority of
the money that we make here we invest in
people who don't make money back for us
and I'm not trying to say this because I
love everybody who works at timcast we
got an awesome team of really great
people and they help make it all
possible it is possible to run Tim cast
IRL on Bare Bones with maybe like one or
two people but I want to make sure
nobody's like going crazy and everyone's
comfortable so we have like a handful of
people who have we have people who book
people who who who schedule guests you
know uh uh people who uh will handle the
booking for us do the paperwork
it does require some people if I got rid
of this show and just in my own personal
YouTube channels Revenue probably
wouldn't change that much and I wouldn't
have to worry about any of this I could
take that money that I make from you
guys watching my content I could then
buy a gold bar for two thousand dollars
put in my closet close the door A year
later when I come back the gold bar is
still there that's my that's my gold bar
I will always have it yeah instead you
see but you go and you look at that gold
bar and then you walk out of your house
and the world's on fire Tim yeah that's
the thing I'm I don't I don't know you
that well maybe 45 minutes we spoke but
I could tell the type of person you are
and you wouldn't be satisfied with that
that's it's because I don't care about a
gold bar right so so here's what we have
we have like 35 employees plus
contractors
I make a little bit of money off a bunch
of our shows
um I think cast Castle may be our second
now second most successful show because
we've got a bunch of people sign up to
become members specifically to watch the
shenanigans of the house I think that's
awesome nice
um pop culture crisis our pop culture
show in the red
makes money but in the red and you know
what I don't care but let me explain
something and I I and you know shout out
to the pop culture crisis crew you guys
do a really really great job
we pay them a salary that's guaranteed
income
I don't make that money back how could I
do a deal where I'm like I will pay you
more money or I will give you all of
these things like when a member signs up
you get a cut that's impossible yeah I'm
just losing money but I want this thing
to exist and then here's the best part
let's say I spend five hundred thousand
dollars on on this show
because I want it to exist
and then
they quit that money's gone
crap I could buy gold bars I don't go
anywhere they don't even walk you know
just lock them in a closet what you're
investing in though is if you're
investing in intangible so like the pop
culture crisis culture that's what
you're investing in right there you
don't know what that will turn into and
then and we also look at like uh maybe
some of the ESG stuff where Disney World
fund movies that are just complete
garbage and I'm doing the same thing be
in the red but they're pushing a culture
they're pushing some they better not be
garbage Tim don't do it no no this is
what people need to get impact invest
Fox News Fox News
the daily wire uh Epoch times whatever
I'm not trying to call anybody out
specifically but they're they're in the
business of making money they of course
probably believe something like a lot of
what they're doing you wouldn't start a
business selling birdhouses unless you
like making birdhouses
but I don't need the company to make
money so this is what I'm saying about
Crowder being right what we're doing and
what Crowder needs to do is different
Crowder will will be rich for the rest
of his life he has nothing to worry
about what Crowder needs to do now is
take that those resources from those who
care about them those who respect his
voice and believe in the movement when
they buy bug club and when they invest
he needs to then do exactly what he's
saying that's why I say he's completely
right he's like I will sign you I will
get you this deal yes
because Disney is doing ESG they're
hiring woke people at a loss because
they want the politics I'll play the
same damn game
I could invest all of my money in
something much easier you know I could
call a wealth management guy and be like
look we're making eight figures take all
the money all the profit and invest it
in in BlackRock and Vanguard whatever
garbage company that wants to destroy
the planet I'm doing that
so uh you know I mentioned like we fall
on private planes I've got a Model S
I'll tell you exactly why the model is
I don't want to Model S I don't want an
expensive car
but I can't just have money sitting in
the bank that is not a reality it
devalues over time yeah especially with
the way inflation was going what ends up
happening is I'm sitting there and we
have like profit come in and I'm like
okay
I have this money that came in
I want to invest in something
we have to have a certain amount in our
savings account to run the business
because when covet happened Revenue
dropped to like we basically were
sitting on top of red and that was that
was a scary thing to see happen now I've
got 30 plus employees I can't go in the
red if we don't have that rainy day fund
right people don't get paid yeah okay
can't do that also can't just have cash
in the bank it's it's losing value and
people want raises so you have to buy
something that will retain its value so
property in any capacity well I I really
relate to your story and and this is I
think why I'm a fan of yours is because
you don't need to be doing what you're
doing in terms of fighting in the
culture war and yet you're doing it and
this is actually one of my major
disagreements with the old guard of the
libertarian party is that they they
really abdicated their Duty in terms of
engaging in the culture War at all you
know they just said let people do as
they see fit and that's not our business
we just want the government out of it
and and while obviously I agree with
that sentiment I think at the end of the
day the reason that Michael Knowles and
Matt Walsh and these other people get to
drag us through the mud and pretend as
if we're you know degenerates and we
have no uh moral Fabric or you know
culture to ourselves at all as they
should that well they should they should
be doing that but they're wrong and and
I think it's because we didn't engage in
that fight so I love that you like you
were talking on the show last night
about creating the coffee shops with the
skate shops and and having your or our
crew of media that's you know playing as
opposed to having CNN playing in the gym
and things like that exactly I think
it's so important that you're doing that
and and the other reason I relate to
your story is because I was a I ran a
private mortgage company and I was
making a half a million dollars a year
and I had no employees and I was just
raking I was just doing great and I did
that for 10 years and then the lockdowns
happened and I was like oh I've been
ignoring the insanity of our world for
too long 2020 strikes obviously lunatics
are in charge of us they lock us down
they screw up everything and I'm like
well I need to do something about this
so I shut down my company I start
liberty lockdown and then Tower gang
it's like at some point things get so
dire that we're forced to engage and and
if you want to ignore that I could have
done the same thing I could have gone
out and buyed uh bought bars of gold but
then I'm in I'm in a world that's hell
so why would I do that if I if I could
just tag on to what you were saying a
couple days ago you had the crass and
steam Brothers on and they said
something that bothered me uh everything
they say bye no no something that I kind
of like it really stuck with me they
said uh they don't like that Republican
legislature is uh making laws against or
focusing too much on culture I'm
probably paraphrasing it wrong they said
they shouldn't they care too much about
social issues correct yeah that's what
they said they I mean I think that that
you guys are completely over the target
if you have pinpointed an issue in this
Society a linchpin that is well I mean
it's holding them together but you you
guys are right over it and when the left
sees that or whoever it may be when they
see that they kind of start to get
frazzled and they said it out loud which
to me was like kind of amazing but I've
I've heard it before multiple times
where you're calling someone out that's
what they're doing in does anyone ever
talk about the health care policies of
Iran
no what do they talk about
what does the left talk about when it
comes to countries like Iran or or Saudi
Arabia women's rights yeah women Optics
treatment of gay people that's true so
what happens is on the right you have
the vanguards of social order
where they're saying like guys
if we go down that path no one will ever
care about health care policy because
people will be dying the left like the
krasensteins they're more liberal
they're more default liberal they're
like I don't understand why culture
matters I'm concerned about someone
getting health care or a job and I'm
like that's Downstream from where we're
at it's I agree with you but when when
the cultural apparatus is completely on
that side there every time I open my
eyes or like if I turn on my phone or
the TV it's something from a
left-leaning cultural establishment oh
yes it's kind of hard for me to separate
these two things
so it's so monopolized I really believe
that if we don't engage in that fight
then the future Generations are owned by
their dictates and we stand no chance so
we have no choice but to engage and the
people that actually have Financial
capital or success or brand recognition
or name recognition that exists in our
space as far as I'm concerned maybe it's
altruistic maybe it's too haughty and
lofty but I think that we have a duty to
engage in their Arena the one that they
don't want us to be engaging in yeah one
of the issues up to this point the
libertarian has had I think is that it's
it's very Live and Let Live Like You Do
you according to politics like your
politics but then they also said that
about culture like whatever but the
reality is we are embedded in each
other's realities like culturally
regardless of our politics I'm so down
with letting you do your own politics
over there but if it's altering the way
my kids view their gender or exactly or
changing the way my kids think I'm
involved no matter what my voice this is
why I have such a harsh disagreement
with the reasons and the Cato Institutes
of the world that that frame us as being
basically we are not allowed we're not
permitted by their establishment
libertarian Inc Banner to engage in this
discussion whatsoever they don't want us
to comment on you know ESG and CRT and
any of the things that are going into
our culture which is like gutting our
civilization and I take that very
seriously and most Libertarians I know
do as well so when people recognize you
know Cato or Reason as the standard
barriers for libertarianism it drives me
insane and that's why uh crowd has done
that multiple times yes but I want to
read these these we got a couple super
chats and this is a this is a really
good example of one of the biggest
problems that we have in the culture War
we got blunt news it says Tim telling
all his employees he doesn't need them
right to their face in front of the
world you're welcome to the five dollars
it's the last another guy says Tim you
need a slice a humble pie no let me
speak for that bro that's being honest
with me that's the first not even it let
me you basically said your employee ways
are inconsequential have some respect
for the people who took the risk but
this is the point the view of those
super Chatters is the purpose of the
business is to make money no if I'm
going to do anything in terms of leading
a culture War charge it's impossible
without the people who work at this
company Bingo the money is garbage
that's the point I don't need it I'd
rather I'd rather hire someone like
Shane Cashman so that he can write these
stories and profile people like Carrie
Lake and and uh and Kanye yeah and an
article the way I've explained it is
what would I rather have an infinity
pool or for the world to be able to read
a breakdown of what happened in that
courtroom with Carrie Lake for the world
to have that article so when when
someone says like Tim saying his
employees are inconsequential oh you
misunderstand they're inconsequential to
me making money but who the cares if I
make money we all care if fact-based
news is being written hey guess what
we're News Guard certified over
timcast.com that's only possible thanks
to our Newsroom does The Newsroom make
money it makes a little bit but I spend
more on it why because it is more
important to have these people able to
do the world-changing things they do
than for me to buy gold that's the point
how about this I could if I was that
kind of guy be like I'm the one who
makes the money why do I need anyone
else for but I don't care about that
when you guys become members of
timcast.com when you guys Super Chat I'm
basically saying who else can I Empower
to try and change the world yeah and it
really is crazy
and I think about it I'm like man
like some of the stuff that's been
produced by like you know shout out to
Shane Cashman the news team pop culture
crisis I'm like this stuff is going to
last forever and it is infinitely more
valuable than any material object the
abstract ideas that are produced and I
gotta give a shout out to Shane because
I think him profiling the Cary Lake
trial is a piece of history that needed
to exist and I am eternally grateful
that you guys watching made that
possible he's one of the best writers I
have ever yes I just want to talk about
the Crowder situation here a little bit
because I think Kreider was kind of
insulated away from the business aspect
of what's really going on in this media
Sphere for a very long time when he was
working at The Blaze and when he's when
he's you know given these contracts a
lot of the times a lot of these
businesses usually do very high asks in
the beginning you get a lawyer you
negotiate it down there's there's a long
process here where you got to go back
and forth and there are a lot of
competitive very Cutthroat individuals
in this game that we do have to address
that do care about themselves rather
than the overall message so when Crowder
says that I I agree with him and it's
because of these contracts because of
you know a lot of these Cutthroat uh
individuals why I personally have been
independent my entire career I'm very
happy that I've been independent I'm
very happy that I'm able to do what I
want and if I could talk to Crowder if
he's listening thing I would say hey
your Freedom's a lot more valuable than
being under any kind of contract or or
you know mandatory thing that you have
to do for this show I volunteer here
because I like to do this but at the
same time I don't want any kind of
responsibilities I don't want any kind
of Duties I want to do what I want to do
and having that kind of freedom is more
important than anything else I've been
doing this since 2006. I had my own
members area for eight years on
lucenser.com I have a lot of fun doing
this and and and Independent Media is
supposed to be independent and I think
he has a pathway right now to do a lot
of good I disagree with some of his
larger political ideas but I I think
what he's dealing with right now is just
the reality of the current situation
that he's speaking about so I'm kind of
happy that he he is speaking out against
this and bringing attention to it I'll
put it this way we Luke and I had a
conversation a while back about him you
know being being a recurring guest or
co-host and ultimately it was like
a a work exchange doesn't make sense
between the fact like both of our
different companies and so it looks like
well I like coming on the show and then
Luke finds his own way to monetize and
that's okay you know you don't gotta be
here you can be here if you want to be
here regarding it's it's a it's a mutual
agreement right it's not nothing's
forced nothing nothing is expected we
just do what we do we we love talking to
each other I love being on the show and
it's it's a fun time and I you know it's
it's a pleasure abruptly it's super
important I'll give you like at least
two weeks and I give you the kind of
stamp I'm like hey I'm gonna be coming
here for a few months then leaving but
we but we've we've talked about like
Luke being on permanently but Luke runs
his own company Luke travels so and and
to be honest with you it's going to be
very difficult to you know pay me
because like I value my time a lot right
and it's going to be a lot of money to
be able to have me not do what I want to
do well exactly there's a really good
point actually Luke you have your own
t-shirt company you have your own show
you have your own website you have your
own business entities how could I do a
contract deal with Luke because like the
thing you'd understand about employment
when you're an employer
in the space you work you own what is
produced by the employee
so like if you get hired by a music
production Studio to make music
guess what your music is owned by that
if like they hire you and say we're
hiring you to write songs correct you're
not going to go write a song and then be
like oh but someone's mind I wrote it
later it's like no we hired you to write
music you don't keep it
so there's no way like we you know we
could we could do something it's I mean
I can't own Luke's social media I think
the the nature of the problem really is
that many of these creatives or these
creators they have an audience but
they're not business people and I think
that's what differentiates some of you
guys in this or actually all of us in
this room is that we have a real
entrepreneurial bent that allows us to
create that Revenue stream that allows
us to continue to speak the truth and
and not be beholden to anybody I didn't
I didn't really have this kind of
entrepreneurial band or understanding of
business either
um but you do now well yeah yeah because
I studied like missing and economics
right but it's kind of amazing to rise
to this level of like no of notoriety
and still like especially in speaking in
the political realm still not understand
the economics behind it it's kind of
baffling that's why immediately when I
saw it I thought there's something more
nefarious going on and Tim's just
explaining no it's just like a numbers
issue yeah I don't I don't I don't blame
the company who made the contract mostly
because I don't know what the fee is and
that's really important but it changes
everything yeah but the contracts the
whole like we own your persona your in
perpetuity forever henceforth we own the
right to the Stephen Crowder care
they'll be deep faking him and making
him say stuff after he's dead like you
cannot these are old contracts from
1990s that they're still trying to
pigeonhole into modern era what they
should be doing assigning contracts roll
that 20-sided give me I'm Gonna Roll 100
I'm saying that that D I got a 96.
that D20 with only 20s
absolutely right but what they should be
doing is signing Tech contracts with
Crowder so that they do all his back end
stuff he can keep doing exactly what he
likes to do and they're taking a piece
off the top five percent eight percent
ten percent after cost three percent
after cost not trying to hit a gold mine
with the next big up and coming because
it used to be that people didn't control
their own proliferation of art you had
to go to the network then they would
proliferate it for you now you
proliferate your own stuff and we need
to treat these artists with that kind of
respect knowing that I think I think
part of the reason that not just the
culture but the economy has also been
taken over and dominated by the left is
that we've really lost the Competitive
Edge that I think many in the
conservative libertarian sphere once
said where it was like we're going to
find a way to compete with you scumbags
like we're going to find a way and and I
wish that instead of looking at these
contracts and Crowder kind of framing it
as him being a victim of it he were to
say I'm going to I'm going to replace
you you offer me these terrible deals
because if it's if you can do that then
do it yeah you don't need to complain if
someone sent me this contract I would
take a dump on it no I rolled the 20 by
the way I get the F out what you should
do is I'm a free human being I get to do
what I want you want to monetize and
control every aspect of my existence the
hell freaking that's important because I
could do a way better job at it myself
and that no one's going to be
controlling me or pulling my strings
that's what he said to me
don't let your emotions charge up when
you get insulting offers just stay cool
and counter offer it with what you with
more than what you want even give it to
them give it back you know and if they
laugh at it then walk away or or
renegotiate but we're not we're not
talking about you know 17 year old
Taylor Swift signing a crappy contract
we're talking about a 30 something year
old man or 40. I don't even know how old
he is you're not a big Personality yeah
you're not a victim here well I got what
I would say to Stephen is um
I think
you know he's been he's been working
with the blaze for so long he's not he's
not been in the space it's kind of like
you know when when you're in a
relationship for a decade and then you
break up or divorce or whatever and
you're going back in the dating pool and
you're like whoa this is crazy shark
tank yeah like what do they expect of me
right so I see this and I'm like again
the first and most important thing is
what's the fee because you know Luke was
mentioning if I got a contract take a
dump on it but look what if they offered
you 200 million dollars
one year
what's your number Luke 200 million
dollars one year I gotta read the
contract I gotta read all of it for sure
that would be good but like but but if
they're gonna destroy everything I do
on it they could delete his YouTube
account with that content you could do
unspeakable things to me for 200 million
dollars unspeakable what was Kanye's
yeah you reached a certain point when
you have so much money it doesn't really
matter right that's why I don't
understand a lot of these kind of
Associates I got that kind of money I
don't understand
yeah but who cares I'll tell you the
number is probably like 200 000 per year
and then everything afterwards is
confusing it depends on true for me I'll
tell you my story uh you know everybody
knows I grew up on south side of Chicago
poor family
I remember when I bought Pokemon Red I
worked at my family's coffee shop it was
we took out loans put the house as
collateral to get it end up losing the
house when everything fell apart but I
remember working for tips saving up 30
bucks and then going buying Pokemon Red
and I was like wow that was so hard for
me to do and I knew kids whose parents
bought them red and blue just because it
was like it was only three bucks we
would care my dad makes six figures
right I was like oh my dad makes 30 000
a year so I had to work really hard for
that
so for people who grow up with a really
high standard of living it's hard for
them because they're so used to it I've
met a lot of people who were born to
families who are you know Millionaires
and when they're older they're panicking
about not making 500 000 a year because
they're like how do I hang out with my
friends they're flying to Ibiza next
week I got fired from my job and I'm
only I got an offer it's 125k I can't
fly to a visa on that and I'm laughing
like I've never flown to a PC I can't
relate to those people to be honest
right even though even though I've made
money like they have so what's up
happening is I get uh I work for vice
vice paid me 85 000 to start because I
said guys I don't care about the money I
could probably come in here and tell you
with everything behind me you got to pay
me a lot of money you'd probably say yes
I want guarantees and I I laid out the
business guarantees that I wanted and
said if that's what you you can give me
then the money needs to get me an
apartment and pay my bills and they said
okay 85 000 but we give you these three
guarantees deal
after a few months I said you're falling
short on two of the guarantees that
means you're not paying me what we
negotiated the money is ancillary they
said okay we're going to get you these
things to make it up for you we'll give
you another we'll give you another 15
grand per year I said okay I'm at 100.
after about a year and a month or so I
came to them and said guys we've had
three meetings I really appreciate
everything you've done for me I quit and
they were like I can't believe you're
kidding who quits Vice nobody quits Vice
Fusion offered me 250 000 per year for
two years plus two hundred thousand
dollars in in writing in my hands to
take that job
so I sit down with them and they say
they wrote it down and I laughed and I'm
like
they would offer me money more money if
I asked instead I said okay how about
this instead of paying me more money I
want 300 000 a year in production budget
at my discretion and 25 000 in Tech at
my discretion and they said
so we don't pay you that it's just
towards what you're making like yeah and
they're like okay deal why like in their
mind they were thinking like we would
have given this guy that money for his
pocket and I'm like no no it's easier to
negotiate that I want to make something
important
and then for them they don't lose any
money they were like we're probably
gonna but but what it does for me is
contractually guaranteed me the ability
to travel do whatever I wanted to do
without impedance because I had my own
budget I gotta do I had a very similar
story by the way and I won't I don't
want to mention names here uh but it but
it's someone prominent that I previously
looked up to and I was like I really
want to work for these guys they're like
what do you want I'm like just pay me
the minimum let me fly around the world
I was broke I didn't have a job I just
really loved to do this I was like fly
me around the world I'll cover events
I'll do it for for bare minimum they're
like okay is 70 000 okay I'm like yeah
sure I'll risk my life for that I'll
cover riots I'll cover that I'll get
arrested I don't care
um and they're like okay fine I went
down there signed the contract met the
CEO we signed it together had a dinner
shook hands and I'm like yeah I'm gonna
have a job I packed up my car was ready
to move this was at the peak of my
career during Occupy Wall Street and I
remember just getting the best coverage
and this contract said you can't
monetize your own stuff you can't do
everything and I was getting record
views the most views on my YouTube then
ever doing live streams interviewing
Lupe Fiasco all these celebrities and
then they stopped taking taking my phone
call and then they stopped answering my
text messages and then they stopped
answering emails and I contacted on one
person a second person a third person
and they all started ignoring me and I'm
like what the hell's going on here and
then a couple weeks later like oh yeah
sorry we don't have enough money which
was a lie you're uh too bad and now I
lost out on some of the biggest income
that I could have made I lost out on
business opportunities and I'm like you
know this is what I get for trying to
work with anybody I'm not going to be
working with anybody I'm going to be
independent I'm going to continue to be
independent even though I'm struggling
even though I'm not getting any money
this is why I created my members area
and and Lucan sensor.com which it is
right now and I made my own way and I'm
a lot happier and looking back at it I
am so happy I didn't work for that
company because that company had its own
legal problems and more importantly I
have my own thing that I built myself
that I'm super proud of more than ever
and no one could take that away from me
I want to address some of the super
chats they're right they're they're
saying Crowder's not not claiming to be
a victim he's calling out a few things
one the massive penalties and the uh
that they're based on if you get a
strike on YouTube or apple they'll
they'll dock you fees yeah I can explain
that
um again Crowder is right not to do a
contract like this but imagine I say to
you all right uh uh top Tower gang guys
I I've seen how much how much your
podcast makes
let's do a deal right now you guys make
I'm just gonna we're gonna do random
magic numbers because I don't know how
much you guys make but let's so I see
that you guys this year made five
million dollars amazing job last year
you made 4.8
I think that if I sign you and manage
the ads on your show I'll take your
workload down by 25 but increase your
Revenue growth 40 year over year because
we have a big network of ads so here's
what I'll do you got no reason to sign
with me unless I pay you more than 5
million right well it looks like you're
on a trajectory to do 200 000 more this
year than last year I'll make it 500
000. I will guarantee you 5.5 this year
and six in the next year for a two-year
contract
guarantee you that money
okay now what happens if you only have
upside though what oh yeah yeah okay and
then after that guarantee you know we
take 10 of your Revenue right whatever
the deal is
uh so that way or it's probably gonna be
like 20 because like we're doing a
guarantee I'm giving you a growth
guarantee but I'm so confident I can
make more money that after we do this
guarantee I know I'm gonna make that
five mil I'm gonna make 5 million this
year off your show so I'm getting that
money back you're getting guaranteed
growth I'm doing the work to grow it and
then after that growth you still keep 80
of it but here's the thing what if I do
this contract with you and then you go
and start ranting about a cabal of
people with tiny hats and then all of a
sudden you get banned from every
platform and then I'm like my guy
I can't pay you money there's no money
to pay you and you're like you
guaranteed me five five and then six pay
up that's you know you have to have
these in the contract otherwise you're
basically just burning cash potentially
with a you know some crazy cancel
culture world we live in you have to be
prepared for that you just have to so I
I imagine you know the deal with Crowder
is they said we're gonna pay you you
know let's I don't know the number but
let's say they were like we'll give you
15 million dollars per year guaranteed
no matter how much membership you bring
in no matter how many ads you sell we
will take the risk on our end
so so here's what I imagine happens they
go to Crowder and they say I'm looking
at your numbers
I'd be willing to bet because we don't
know because the blaze has those numbers
but you know this other company is
probably not the blaze because he left
the blaze it might be the place it might
be it might be his contract renewal for
all we know and a lot of people I know
everybody's saying they think it's a
daily wire but there are a lot of
companies in the space and this could be
him re-upping his contract and then
getting angry and that's why he left we
don't know it could be Fox too I mean
look look how small those uh letters
look right it could say fox it could say
uh fnc Fox News Corporation so imagine
they go to him and say
it looks like you make
based on your numbers 12 million per
year we'll give you 15. that means we
are going to risk three million dollars
of our money that we don't know if we'll
get back
that also means if you're willing to
accept three million more dollars per
year that you normally don't get
you have to be responsible in terms of
how these platforms operate
that means if Facebook gives you a
strike if YouTube gives you a strike and
you can't make that money here's what
we're going to do we're going to give
you a flat percentage docking on our
guarantee now here's what a lot of
people think it's a bad thing but think
about this
if you get a strike on uh and I do think
the contract is bad by the way but I'll
explain
if you get a strike on YouTube you guys
got to strike you got two strikes you
can't produce for 90 days right so
that's one that's that's 25 yeah of a
year since of the whole year no money
can be generated on this platform and
they won't even tell me what I said
wrong well they might so imagine let's
hope somebody says I'll do a deal with
you where I'll guarantee you money but
if you get knocked out for three months
We're not gonna pay you that money
correct here's what I think with this
contract Stephen was offered the fees
exorbitant
the response from Crowder
in my opinion should have been a
response with remove the fees right
assume the risk and we got a deal yeah
counter yeah
um but I think that the issue is as he
points out he's in a position to to say
no to this and younger people aren't and
the fees listed in this contract are
ridiculous they're 20 25 for a YouTube
strike like dude one YouTube strike is
two weeks not not three months no it's
actually one one strike I think is only
one week and then it's two weeks and
then it's permanent but it's still you
have to you you reconfigure the entire
nature of the show after you receive
those strikes because you have to like
completely reformulate your brain to try
and stay safe
um but the the reason that I framed it
as Crowder kind of behaving in a victim
mentality and if he's doing it just to
look out for young creators that he he
doesn't want them to go down this path
God bless it seemed as if he was putting
himself a little bit more in that
position and the reason I bring it up is
because you know when I work for someone
else I never made more than six figures
except for one year in my life and as
soon as I started working for myself for
a decade I made you know three four five
hundred thousand dollars you don't get
paid as much as you're worth unless
you're willing to take the risk of
working for yourself and that's just a
truth it's just reality and so many
young people and I'm not saying Crowders
in this camp but so many people they
don't want to take that risk anymore
they don't want to have all of the
pressure but they still want that golden
parachute of working for some
Corporation that's going to make their
life really smooth and easy that's just
not reality you have to take these risks
if you want to get those outsized
returns so if Crowder is making crazy
money already I understand why he would
crap on this contract as you've said but
at the same time you know
and I was in a very similar position as
an independent journalist I was I was
incurring a lot of risk I didn't have
health insurance I was getting injured
in the field I was getting arrested
didn't have lawyers didn't have anyone
to bail me out I had nothing I was like
I need someone to make sure if I get
injured or hurt that I could still pay
the medical bills if I get arrested
there's there's a lawyer there that's
going to bail me out I had none of that
and that's why I wanted to work with
someone and then you know I got screwed
over by this one company that really
hurt me financially uh and I was like
that's it screw it I just got to do it
on my own and people don't understand
when you make a profit essentially a lot
of people look down on you like oh
you're making a profit like that profit
is is for insurance that profit is my
retirement that profit is me getting
hurt and injured seriously being able to
eat yeah people don't understand I need
to eat I I need to live and and if
there's medical bills that I'm gonna
have in the future I'm on those on
myself right no one else this is why I
got so angry that I couldn't record
today
like this morning I'm sitting here angry
I took ibuprofen because ibuprofen
reduces swelling and allows you to talk
that's the only reason I was able to
record yesterday but you can only take
so much because it stops the mucous
production your stomach and then you get
ulcers so I'm like
if I don't work employees don't get paid
you will now with the direct
subscriptions monthly you can take days
exactly it's a lot of easy this is
important too and thank you for bringing
that up if when we're on the ad model
when we had no memberships I knew that
if I did not work one day that meant
money was gone that goes to employees
granted like look we have healthy
profits so it's basically me just being
like I lose money
I have to pay for it I don't get a paid
time off I have to I have to eat that
and dish it out with memberships it's
almost like now you guys are are you
know all standing together holding this
place up so I so this morning I'm like I
need to take this morning off and give
my voice sometime yeah that's actually
what a lot of them want in the comments
like please rest we enjoy your content
yeah well I mean see this I I totally
get it though because I was an
entrepreneur and it like it does it
pained you not so much because of what
damage it does to you but because of the
vision you have for like who you're
gonna bring on I know you've brought on
Phil uh from All That Remains I believe
recently yeah uh Josie libertarian I
know she does some outside media work
for you guys too and it's like these are
these are all things that if you don't
continue to grind you don't get to grow
and assist these people and allow them
to have a platform like the fact that
you bring on smaller shows like ours
Tower gang or liberty lockdown or
whoever else and you do it every day
it's such a huge like benefit to our
movement and I know we're all you know
have our own little niches and things
like that I'm more the and cap
libertarian variety you guys have
conservatives that come on but like this
is this it's a very small world man
that's the one thing I've noticed as
I've traveled around there are so few
outlets for people like us I'm glad to
see that there's competitors that are
entering the space we need a hell of a
lot more of it and God bless them and
and if it's daily wire the Blazers
whoever's drafting these contracts I
hope you guys will reflect on on the
nature of them and and hopefully you'll
improve it don't prove Kanye right
um but but I I we do need we need more
people that are that are willing to
engage in this in this Arena and and if
you're not willing to take the risk then
then just understand that you're not
going to get the maximal rewards I I
didn't take vacations for over five
years I I paid everything out of pocket
um and at the end of the day I had an
enormous amount of liability that was
laying out there in my loan book that I
could have been dragged through court
for the rest of my life you know and
people don't ever look at that side of
things they just go like well you've
made a lot of money so you owe
civilization and you're a bad guy and
it's like it's not real man I want how
it goes yeah I want to clarify too
because people people are super chatting
a lot like no Tim you don't understand
Crowder said this is no no no no no look
look Crowder is completely right I
commented he's like right about all of
it the issue is that these companies are
operating as these companies have to
operate for what they are and as Ian
pointed out this is like the 90s way of
doing things this doesn't work anymore
in the modern era Stephen Crowder is the
entrepreneur and the personality so
he can make there's no need for a
network the guys who run these networks
like Fox News or whatever they're not on
TV they're not telling you their
thoughts they're not leading the charge
in the culture War they're not producing
content they're managing a business yeah
well in today's day and age that
person's the employee not the boss so
right now what happens is someone who
should be an employee is offering a
contract to Stephen Crowder Stephen
Crowder should be the boss exactly
Stephen Crowder's supposed to be the one
being like look I'm the captain of the
ship it's inverted exactly and that's
the problem with the system it's been
that way for a long time now that being
said
there are going to be a lot of people
who do not have what it takes to run a
business because this is what I was
trying to get to you know when I was
mentioning earlier about how it would be
so much easier just to like get rid of
everything and just do my own YouTube
channels it is extremely hard to to run
and manage and maintain all this stuff
oh yeah man it's like 16 hours
and the value in it is I don't want to
leave this world with a bunch of
crackpot you know psychotic occultists
of a non-theistic religion you know
controlling things and I you know don't
get started from because I'm like I
really hate liars you know it's like
when I started this I was like I want to
travel and tell people what I'm seeing
do new stuff and then all of a sudden
they lied about everything I did Sweden
and then I'm like okay I'm gonna call
you after a lying and then that's like a
big component of it these people are
evil they lie every day look what they
did to Kyle Rittenhouse just like I mean
they try to they they've still
negatively impacted this kid's life they
tried to destroy it so that's that's
what it's all about and that means we're
entering an interesting space
there is infinitely more power in ESG
businesses like Disney than in say like
the daily wire now you're speaking my
language but this is the challenge
how do you compete like the daily wire's
got to make money Disney doesn't yeah
facts and the reason they don't is
because of their relationship to the
government and and the world economic
forum and all of the the oh go ahead
it's you're mostly right I was just
going to say also that
they own so much IP true that the
average person will just pay the 10
bucks because they're like I can watch
Flubber yeah well and I think that
the audience is not going to like this
but at the end of the day we do need to
as consumers of this media the people
that want to see something different in
the world that isn't you know perverted
and messing up our children you need to
you need to put your money where your
mouth is you can't just continue to
consume free content this is why you
know we have to diversify we're on
rumbles of course Liberty
lockdown.locals.com as well for people
that want to support the show so that I
can actually tell the truth if I can get
enough people that are doing that then I
don't have to worry about de-platforming
and things like that but the ESG factor
in this is such a big deal and and I it
drives me crazy because ultimately it's
becoming a partisan issue where you have
red State Governors are really really
engaging in this and God bless them we
need it but at the same time I wish it
weren't partisan in nature I wish we
understood that that having a a
monolithic globalist perspective on how
to utilize and manipulate Capital
markets to try and reimagine the world
in your image well you're not always
going to be in charge just the same same
concept of like do you want Donald Trump
to have these Powers no you don't well
then maybe it's not okay when Biden does
it same same concept with ESG yes right
now it is being utilized to to uh
propagate a very
neoliberal World Order well what if that
what if that Dynamic changes because it
inevitably will maybe it'll be a hundred
years but it's going to change at some
point do we want big business to be
reimagining our civilization like the
answer to me is clearly no particularly
when it's nameless faceless Bankers that
are primarily uh responsible for this
stuff or if they are known they're
they're at Davos with 500 security
guards yeah five thousand and hookers
five thousand was it five thousand
soldiers oh my God that were given
police power or coercion if you need 5
000 soldiers to protect yourself you're
doing something wrong you're doing
something wrong and and like I'm not I I
don't I'm not at all wanting them to be
threatened or injured at all but there's
a reason that people are so concerned
about your
you're trying to manipulate and coerce
the entire world we're talking eight
billion people that you want all to live
in this particular worldview where
carbon emissions are such a danger where
the thing that I exhale makes me a
danger to every man woman and child on
Earth it's a very anti-human perspective
and ultimate ultimately it's
anti-capitalist this is one other
talking point that I have to get across
is that this is not capitalism that
we're dealing with and when people talk
about it as if it is it drives me
absolutely insane this is a fascistic
model correct crystal clear fascistic
model and you can't then hold that up
and say look at all of these evil things
that are happening in our world this is
why we have to go towards socialism
we're basically down that path already
you know the big challenges these ESG
companies
ESG is the require is is the
prerequisite for financial investment
yes so in West Virginia these fossil
fuel companies call or whatever are like
hey you know we need a loan of five
million dollars to expand our operation
hire more employees and they go no
and then someone comes out and says we
want a drag queen story on they're like
oh how much do you need for that and you
know where that money comes from
Federal Reserve how do you compete with
an industry that can print infinite
money for itself
doesn't that make this whole it just
makes it hard it's harder and that means
we need all of these companies that are
in the independent and
anti-establishment space to be operating
on the exact same capacity don't hire
woke people right hire people believe in
Freedom yeah Empower people who believe
in Freedom so this is the point and if
you're a consumer of that media support
people that are providing that that
media you really have to like you have
to if you want to see that you have to
actually contribute so this is you know
basically everything that we do here and
why we do it why do we hire people we
hire because their job is to be a
positive influence on the world and
that's more important than the revenue
we're we're uh an ideological company in
a sense
the other shows make money but Tim cast
makes the overall majority of it and
then that money is the resource that we
use to have people make cool and good
and positive things
I love it we need a hell of a lot more
of it I was just I was just going to
comment on like how absurd it is when
you really think about
um like this whole thing is over fake
money and uh the message that it's that
it the division that it'll cause in the
conservative movement which I'm not a
conservative so whatever but it's just
interesting to see them kind of squabble
over this and it's all just fake money
in the end of the day yeah the federal
reserve prints it out of thin air it's
going to be worthless anyway soon and
he's so proud of you yeah you don't need
to worry about this don't worry it's all
going to be devalued at the end of the
day what are you gonna have your
experiences your own company what you
built yourself don't let anyone else
build anything for you but this is again
my strategy people are built different
this is just who I am after being
through a lot of rough crazy situations
in my life dealing with other businesses
um who knows maybe he'll strive more and
be better under a contract but for me
personally there's a road to take I'm
taking that road I just think it's so
important that we encourage people that
that share our value system and have the
drive that we do in this room to
actually follow that passion and follow
that path because there's just been such
a dearth of entrepreneurial spirit and I
get it I get it you are it's so stacked
against you especially if you're like a
young college graduate and you're coming
out and you're like you understand ESG
which obviously makes you a very rare 23
year old or whatever but say you do
understand it you know what an uphill
slog that's gonna be like you're gonna
try and compete head to head with the
biggest businesses that have ever
existed in human history and at the end
of the day they have a you know a
sweetheart deal with all of the biggest
governments on earth oh on top of that
they have a sweetheart deal with the
central banks of the world where they
can just buy Fiat create debt and credit
like I get it but it doesn't matter we
have to compete we have to try if we
just acquiesce and we we were talking
about the black people earlier right
that's true yeah if we give up it's over
right we can't give up right we have to
try one thing you mentioned earlier Tim
is that uh wondering like is everyone
cut out to run a company or a business
or something like that along those lines
the answer is no no they're not and
there's a difference that's important to
keep in mind between a business and a
company a company is a type of business
that involves two or more people which
is why it has come penny with patreon
you know with people company and it's a
companion you know uh business you can
be have a business as a sole proprietor
as soon as you start hiring people or
bringing other people on you become a
company and at that point do you want to
run a company do you want to be involved
with other people's day-to-day activity
do you want to be taking meetings do you
want to be intricately you know
responsible for these people's behavior
that's the question and that's that's
also that's like a it's like an art form
we've been offered deals by
all the big players in the space and all
the deals were bad
and I'm just like
man
I don't know what these companies are
doing we could write a Cool Tech deal
not that we we don't do Tech at timcast
but we could the the tech are you
talking about is this like like an nft
contract is you can explain that uh I
would do like uh uh we would set up
hosting or navigate to some sort of
Hosting like on Rumble build like a
front end and up make sure that it's if
there's bugs that we have developers
that are fixing the bugs on the Fly 24
7. and um so we would technically help
you host your own content and provide
your subscribers a direct Revenue to you
and then we could technically take money
off the top if we wanted to I'm building
a charity right now that's building this
software so ultimately it'll be free for
everyone to use and I'm not taking
anything for it all of these uh all
these companies calling me non-stop like
whenever there's drama you know what I
mean I I don't I don't I I there's
there's a lot that I won't talk about
because I don't think it changes the
political the political landscape you
know if it did I would come out just be
like sorry guys you know but there's
private stuff and I always try to avoid
things that I think might hurt as it's
standard journalistic ethic it's
minimize harm
you uh I've I've talked with the blaze
for years
uh said no every time uh I've talked
with the daily wire I've talked with
Rumble you know there's a couple other
companies that we we've negotiated with
and some we've done deals with and I
just say no to all of them and I think
one of the things these companies don't
get is where we are in the modern
landscape I think they're hoping
I think I think they're hoping that
someone like me is a guy who's like just
wants to sit in the room and go on
camera and then go play ball with it
with his kid or you know Future kid or
something like that or dog or whatever
that's what they're trying to sell you
on
yeah and and they do they they all say
the same thing like you shouldn't be
worrying about this stuff man exactly
you know like let us take care of the
heavy lifting and I'm just like
you know what's gonna happen
I'll tell you what's gonna happen I say
this to every single person I've ever
talked to in any company
and I learned my lesson with Fusion but
I got paid and I use that money to
invest and build this I'm like we're
going to start we're going to be excited
we're gonna get the ball rolling six
months in I'm gonna come to you and say
problem X is solved by Y and you're
going to say okay well I don't have time
to deal with this some will take care of
it and I say no it's a problem in my
life that needs to be solved now for the
show and if I don't have the authority
to do it then I'm going to be in a very
bad mood and then you're not going to be
able to so there's no point in doing
these contracts that and
yeah I just I I think these these
companies they're archaic they can sit
down and explain to you exactly why like
I mentioned like why they do the penalty
deal with Crowder's contract and then
Crowder's appropriate responses that's
insane it wasn't insane 20 years ago it
wasn't insane 30 years ago but it is now
when Crowder is the captain of the ship
and he should be the one running it and
they should be working for him let me
add one thing uh because I I probably
black pulled a lot of people by
demonstrating how challenging it is
going to be to compete and succeed in
this space however because of the the
monopolistic power or at least
oligopolistic power that these operators
have
they don't face a lot of real
competition so when they when there is
genuine competition and and also they're
very bureaucratic they're very slow
moving they become very comfortable
overly confident that is all areas of of
opportunity for for entrepreneurs to try
and rise up there's enormous market
demand for honest dialogue your success
has been very clearly proof of that so
there is market demand but there is also
captured markets that make it very
challenging to enter and compete in that
space but it doesn't mean that we can't
create competing Avenues and platforms I
don't I pray to God that Rumble because
it does seem to be like they're they're
the real deal so far
um I pray to God that them locals these
competition actually rise up and they
create an opportunity for that for that
market demand to be met because there is
a demand an entrepreneur should realize
that I've had private conversations with
several big YouTube channels many of
these uh big channels have contacted me
and said look these contracts are really
bad what do we do we should form a
network blah blah blah and I say no
every time what you're asking is
impossible the network model won't work
so here's an idea that's been floated
around by a bunch of people you know and
love behind the scenes so I'll leave
nameless because it's their business but
I'll tell you about what my experience
I get phone calls we do group calls and
they're like we need to compete we need
to change the game how can we do it
let's create a network
let's create a single destination for
all these big creators and then we'll
figure out a way to split the revenue
and I say okay how do you split the
revenue
um we can do it by when someone signs up
they can write down the name of someone
what if they write on nothing what if
they sign up as a general member where's
that money go well we split it evenly is
that fair what if I'm getting 60 million
per month and you're getting 500 000 I'm
giving you half the money that comes in
sure it's not fair to me why would I do
that what if you're getting 100 million
and I'm getting 50 million I get half
your money that makes sense I'm making a
third of of the revenue
so I've had these conversations over and
over again because everybody wants to
coalesce and use this network the idea
is there is an individual out there
who's like man I love Tim guest and then
he goes man I love Crowder I'm not going
to spend 10 bucks for either of them
wait a minute they're bundled together
and 10 bucks gets me both now I'll do it
sure that's what these people think will
happen but what ends up happening is
someone like Crowder with six six
million followers will get half a
million people to watch on Election
night he'll get 50 000 people to sign up
instantly and then good luck sorting who
signed up for who and how much everyone
deserves you might be able to set it up
so you have to toggle who you're signing
up for in order to sign up or everyone
has their own unique links and websites
but it goes to the same centralized
thing so uh Crowder has Mud Club you
have yeah yeah so but they all go to the
same place and they all get everything
in a bundle well so that means I'm
giving my content away for free and
someone's giving 10 bucks you give a
small percentage right how do you
determine the percentage
um you could do it by viewership who
gets uh the percentage of viewership
it's going to be complicated it's nice
I'm not saying I have the solution well
I'm just I'm just spitballing it's
impossible I don't know because if I was
signing up say it's you and Steve
Crowder are splitting it I sign up and I
pick I have to pick you or Steve in
order to sign up so you have that data
and then if there's a smart contract
behind the scenes where the this is
futuristic but if the money is split
automatically
72 percent to you 28 to Stephen based on
the subscriber data I would that might
work
you know what will happen
let's say Bob jimin and Jill do this
deal Bob's got a million Jim's got 500
000 Jill's got five million you know
she's a very attractive you know
podcaster everybody wants to follower
and then uh the money comes in and then
you've got this big jumbled mess of
numbers
763 896 the first week 430 896 a second
week you got 13 signed up for Jill seven
percent said Bob you know 12 said you
know Jim or whatever name I remember the
name I used and then one day someone
goes in and says yeah hold on man I only
got paid 300 000 this month I normally
we do 500 what happened well let's look
at the numbers no no that can't be right
how are you getting more money than me
this is everybody fights everybody else
it's not gonna work it does sound like
an optimal situation for a smart
contract system to be developed where
you could automate the payments based on
the math behind the scenes everything's
on a blockchain or open source so if you
have questions you just take it up with
the math that'd have to be a really
smart
contracts the question is timcast.com is
wholly independent with no investors
with uh no no outside financing just
customers and and advertisers the
advertisers are almost entirely
programmatic meaning we have very very
few direct sponsors I think we have like
eight or ten it changes with the podcast
audio version obviously you guys know we
do virtual Shield bio trust like that's
basically the only two sponsors we have
them periodically do pepper speak stuff
and then uh for the podcast version we
have a handful it's like you know Bambi
and like you know things like that
Hartford gold there's like five or six
and that uh so almost all of it's
programmatic
why would I
create any kind of mud in this company's
Revenue stream by doing a partnership
deal in the hopes that I can increase
Revenue by by a certain percentage by
teaming up with someone like Stephen
Crowder I think you'd only be able to
bring in someone of comparable
clout I hate to use that term but you
know someone that's lesser over
interesting why some would have
comparable clout I mean we're looking at
two people who have comparable amounts
of Revenue who are now going to argue
about the gains and which direction it
goes that's true but I mean there is
there is strength in in networking I
just think you're right though that
obviously a formal Network creates
infighting and jealousy and competition
especially if you have two Alphas that
are like on the on the rise anyways
this this system only makes sense to the
businessman whose sole job is to
maintain it
for for Stephen Crowder and for me there
is zero reason for either of us to do a
network deal because at the end of the
day Steven can pick up his phone and
talk to his phone with no crew with no
employees and he makes money
same thing for me because we are the
people creating the content right so the
people you'll heal at you'll hear advert
advocate for these deals are the people
who do nothing but these deals that's it
yeah they're like if I can bring all
these guys together
I'm gonna make money off the top well
you could do you and Steven together 14
bucks a month so already you're making
seven instead of ten you're gonna take a
hit but then the idea would be you'd get
more like 40 of a of a 10 000 multiple
is better than a hundred percent of a
one times multiple you can't predict it
this is unpredictable that's true a
cultural issue where people are they
want what's uh expedient and not not
what's meaningful so like you know if
you get if you get deleted off of
Twitter you don't exist to me and that's
just the way it is yeah I've seen it a
thousand times and I think you know it's
good that this discussion is out there
right now because people need to start
to like open up their mind to what's
actually going on here like you said we
need to support these creators if it's
ten dollars a month I like Crowder if
it's ten dollars a month I like Tim cast
let's do both I'm not going to spend ten
dollars elsewhere this needs to be out
there more the devastating part about it
is like even though I have a pretty uh
passionate fan base
I get nuked from YouTube for a couple
weeks I I start a rumble Channel up you
still see like even though I have one
tenth the subscribership over on Rumble
my viewership is only cut in half so
like a lot of my people are still
rocking with me even though you know
it's a subscriber limit is is way
reduced
um but it's just it's interesting how
how platform captured people are to make
a uh I have two podcasts two YouTube
channels yes I do I do too I have two
YouTube channels one of them I stopped
using in 2008 it was called cross Mac
and I was like I don't like that people
are calling me cross smack to my face I
want to be branded Ian Crossland so I
made a new Channel people still comment
on Cross Mac that I like oh my God you
still make videos like I'll make a new
video every once while on Cross Mech
they they're not only are they siled on
a platform they're siled on channels yes
yes yes yes yes so we could break that
with a multi-network system too that
would be great you want to know the
worst thing in the world is is YouTube
is like one of the worst platforms uh
let me let me let me do some math real
quick I think on
Apple Spotify and the audio platforms
you will make let me let me let me do
some quick math here or what do we get
um
I think you'll make like five times as
much money off ads
or maybe maybe it's way more than that
oh it's big are you saying versus uh
video oh dude it's huge like for
whatever reason YouTube ad revenue is
gutter trash yes if you can get
25 25 per thousand CPM is kind of
standard on audio like that's 300 300
000 views downloads on a podcast on a
Daily Show you're going to be making
holy crap you're talking 10 7 500. 7 500
per ad
yep it declines as the as the as the ad
goes on but uh you got to be making like
10 million per year if you're if you're
at those numbers easy easy and this is
one on YouTube if you're getting 300 000
you're getting 300 000 views I'll get
you a thousand bucks yeah so you'll make
300 000 per year on YouTube with the
same amount of traffic but they're
depending on your channel too because
like my channel compared to other
channels is getting 30 times less than
what channels are supposed to be getting
what you're saying the three ten to to
to you know sometimes 30. wow yeah but I
confirmed ten well I think that might be
an Ethics violation is just a special
thing like we should not be playing
favorites about it who gets more money
that's like a social justice crap well
YouTube justifies it by saying this
channel is a little bit too spicy and
not Advertiser friendly this channel is
advertising that's how they kind of
justify I counted that is let the
adverts speak to themselves exactly let
that everybody else speak even though
there's not a big difference between the
two content YouTube still deems like hey
this is not good this is good this is
what we like after we just got done
badmouthing networks and saying how
unfeasible all of this is for the past
hour and a half I gotta say that our
boys Dave Smith and Louis J Gomez uh gas
digital they have signed Tower gang to
gas digital I just wanted to shout out
Lewis you're like a brother to me thank
you so much for bringing us on board
your con your contract looks a little
bit like that and I'd like you to work
on it but other than that we appreciate
you uh putting your love and faith tell
me about gas digital real quick gas
digital is basically a largely a comedy
platform and Tower gang being our more
comedy deranged lunatic Outlet we knew
we weren't long for YouTube so we had to
find a platform that would take care of
us in terms of just allowing us to you
know say insane humor wherever it leads
us and gas digital is uncensored so
gasdigitalnetwork.com yep you got it so
you know thinking about the daily wire
for instance because they've signed a
whole bunch of people you know they keep
adding new new Talent my my view when I
look at this stuff is I I maybe it's
just me I personally cannot relate to
the to the desire holy to sign a deal
with another company and have them take
every over to be fair I completely you
know understand the thought of like man
imagine if you could make some out of
money and then you didn't have to think
about any of the business and stuff and
you can just do your show and then mind
your own business but I've been down
that you know that rabbit hole I know
where that goes well it's it's that but
it's also the success and the resources
that you now have at your disposal that
so few creators have you know especially
if you're starting out early on you're
trying to make ends meet so if you have
a network that comes to you and they say
I see Talent here I'm going to guarantee
you a living wage as Bernie Sanders
might say they're going to jump at it
you know what's really funny is that
seeing this story from Crowder this is
the identical story to the record label
stories I was 30 years I was just
thinking that yeah but I also kind of uh
see it as a I think as a Benjamin
Franklin quote where he says uh don't
trade uh Liberty for uh security you'll
get neither this is kind of what's going
on here I mean we did it with covid they
we do it all the time there's result
there there are people who only want to
make music and they're never going to
monetize that music and you got to find
somebody who can but you know I think my
view of this whole thing is like dude if
your personality
of any size hire a manager like and I'm
talking about an employee who works for
you and they do what you tell them to do
or they're fired don't sign a contract
with another guy that makes you the
employee or the quote-unquote the only
reason I consider guests is because you
know as I've already explained I am
financially free I didn't need to go
that route but I don't want to create a
network and a platform that allows for
decensored D or uncensored conversation
uh that's just it's such a huge swing
also his network is filled with the most
hardcore insane comics on Earth I wanted
to be in that world because I'm not a
comedian so it just it made a perfect
perfect fit for us but at the end of the
day you're absolutely right if you can
if you have the willpower and the and
the work ethic it will benefit and
behoove you to go that route I'll tell
you I'll tell you exactly why Tim Cass
is independent because like I said we've
talked with the blaze we've talked with
Rumble we've talked with the daily y we
talked to a bunch of companies and I'm
friends with all of them don't agree
with them on everything of course uh I
nobody owes me anything you know I'm not
going to come out and be like oh this
company came and offered me this I'm
like well they didn't owe me anything
you know what I mean but uh here's the
problem
if I sign a deal with one of these
companies what if I want to get a
billboard on Sunset Strip that says list
Cheney's a fat pig that'd be awesome and
and they're gonna tell me no they're
going to be alive you got to understand
and I'm gonna be like I don't understand
anything dude I work for myself I can
take out a 95 foot tall billboard and
Times Square with my rooster on it I
work for you I gotta go through your
legal team right and they're going to
tell me no and that's just not worth it
especially if one of the goals of your
company is impact investment like you
said earlier like changing the world
that's a lot of corporations are just
profit profit profit if it's not
profitable it's not happening yeah watch
out for that I can imagine chicken city
is very profitable these days right Tim
well it was initially I mean the eggs oh
oh my gosh like a buck a piece
organic chicken eggs yo I told you guys
I gave some to my personal trainer which
I'm so happy thank you so much we just
crack those and drink them I've been
hoddling eggs for like two years
moonshot baby let me let me tell you
guys I'll tell you guys some stuff I
think there's been two instances where
I've reached out to YouTube before a
show to give them give them a warning
and ask for their perspective uh one was
Alex Jones that was obvious I can't
remember the other one but I emailed
like heads up Alex Jones will be coming
on the shows the first time interesting
and uh and they said there's no issues
nothing on our end for us to note on I
said okay well you know fair warning
it's happening then they gave us a
strike
and I immediately contacted them and
said for what reason they gave us a BS
reason I said BS that's not true blah
blah they said we don't care I said how
about the portion you can test we just
snipped from the show and everything's
fine and they said no and then I'm like
you're playing dirty games man so you
know what I did I called up Michael
Mouse and Alex Jones and said when's the
soonest you can come back on the show
we're doing it again hell yeah you sign
a deal with one of these companies you
can't do that right like I'm not an
unreasonable guy but I'm not a fan of
censorship I know that YouTube is trying
to run a business I don't trust them I
think they're an ESD an ESG company but
I also know that when you want to win a
battle you win first you know you win
first then you go to war
ambushing YouTube
it's just like when they tell me in on
paper you're good that's that's legal
Weaponry I can then be like we had we
they were you know they said to me I
abided by the terms it gives me legal
grounds well this is why they won't even
tell me why they struck me and it's also
why they don't want strikes they don't
want that to be in writing they don't
want to give me a time stamp because
then I can actually counter and say well
is this dangerous conspiracy theorist
yes and it's also I think there's a
there's a couple of reasons you know
Matt Gates asked us on Friday how come
we're still here and I'm like you know I
got a variety of verses one of them is I
think YouTube for one they're probably
watching I know a bunch of the employees
watch all the time we consistently have
the most viewed live show for the night
in this time slot and in general but
they also I think know that my
communications with them I've said set
legal groundwork not to dissimilar to
Alex Berenson where if I reach out and
say Alex Jones is coming in the show
here's what we're going to do give me
your advisement and they say you're good
no advisement he's allowed to talk and
then they give me BS
that puts them in an interesting legal
legal position of course well people
need to understand about these deals
with with YouTube Facebook and Twitter
don't think of it as you signed up for a
website think of it like you sat down
with Susan wojcicki or whatever her name
is and said let's do a business deal I
will make a show you distribute that
show sell the ads on it and we'll split
the revenue most goes to me and she said
yes if she breaches that contract and
makes up a reason for it you can sue for
breach of contract and Alex Berenson did
and he won so that that gives you
leverage I also think the size of the
show gives us leverage too to be honest
you think yeah of course you have you
have the ability to actually reach
someone and get an answer I've appealed
multiple times on both of these strikes
they give me nothing I know there's one
based YouTube employee out there
watching right now I need you to help me
people I don't think so look after
liberty lockdown under my strike you
might have to Sue I and honestly I will
if I have to but I don't want to go that
path I'm not I'm not in this for War I
really I'm not I'm a peaceful person at
the end of the day but if you bring it
to my doorstep yeah I'll engage
this is the challenge man the no one
ever said was going to be easy true and
so for people who are listening I'll
tell you this without naming the
individuals who I have been in
communication with people who are making
challenges against YouTube and I'll
leave it at that there's a lot more to
the story of course but let's just say
you know I'm not sitting on I'm not
sitting on my hands as YouTube does
these sensorious things a lot people
message me all the time and they're like
can you email them and tell them and I'm
like no I can't yeah because I've done
it before and they respond with don't
waste our time basically
yeah so incredible some of these terms
where they're like we can ban anyone at
any time for any reason is really
disturbing we had that at mines we were
like we I don't feel right putting this
in the terms like well we kind of have
to change the terms without you even
like uh that's a problem too yeah I
think those term changes should have to
go to Congress any big social media
Network that wants to change the terms
of service should send that to Congress
there should be a bill or something on
the floor where they have to at least
acknowledge it and read it this is a
good point because we didn't did we used
to have like I guess I I don't know I'm
assuming no dude we used to have mass
contracts like this like imagine it's
1950 and a company says everybody you
know oh you want you want to come into
my building everybody sign this contract
giving me the rights over your likeness
and distribution
I'm sure they were like there's waivers
for admittance into buildings and stuff
that have existed but we're talking now
in the scale of 300 million a billion
people who've Mass signed a contract
what happens when Facebook says we've
updated our terms how is sending me an
email that goes to spam do notification
I disagree yeah well it's it's Heaven
just signed it but haven't read it most
of the people haven't read it because
it's too long it's it's too General
people aren't lawyers so that that's
something that does need to get dealt
with and them changing it halfway when
you're invested in the company when you
when you put your entire life your
entire livelihood on a business model
and they just come along say now we're
going to change the business model
retroactively for no reason because we
want to right that's that's just evil it
should be they should send you the full
terms when they change make changes
every every change should be highlighted
and then on the right side of the page
you see all of the granular changes
listed one after the other and then if
you click it it links you right to the
spot in the terms where it happened
that'd be amazing but the the other
thing that really bothers me about this
is that yes the terms of service are is
a constantly moving window so but also I
mean you first off you can cap that at
like say 400 words or something so that
people could actually read it that'd be
nice
um but the thing that really concerns me
most about this misinformation
disinformation Clause that they include
in there is that ultimately many like
I've had Dr Joseph uh ladapo the Surgeon
General of Florida I've had on Dr Robert
Malone I've had on all of these people
who have been either de-platform
censored had smack talked about them
everywhere over the past three years
much of the information that they were
trying to convey in hindsight turns out
to be pretty darn accurate but in that
period if you were to have some of those
people on your YouTube YouTube channel
you would have been struck I mean it's
it's it's crazy the evolution of like
wearing masks and not wearing masks and
wearing masks the guidelines all changed
on YouTube yeah the vaccine transmission
stuff like Sam Harris have you guys seen
this club this this is the episode I got
struck he needs an intervention this man
yes you know what I think happens with
Sam Harris is that he was so scared to
be outside of the liberal mainstream
line and with the intellectual dark web
stuff and when he was with Bill Maher
talking about Islam it was still within
liberal the liberal tribe to say the
things he was saying but he was edgy
then when it came to the lockdowns and
the mandates and all that stuff you
could not deviate and so he stayed with
it and now the information's changed and
he cannot come out and apologize he has
to just keep doubling down the man needs
an intervention if he sat down with
Jordan Peterson and Brett Weinstein and
he said look guys
I was wrong about so much of this and I
was hot-headed will you ever forgive me
I hope they would say yes because I
would I would say sam
welcome back let's get back to the
conversation that's see that's the thing
I've made this pitch many times I just
want you to deal in reality you guys
have lived in your own delusions well
also simultaneously classifying me as
some Vector for you know death uh and
and a misinformation agent and all these
other things look I don't even I don't
even care we bygones be bygones however
you have to face reality and it would be
nice if you were to just say you know
what I overreacted as as opposed to Sam
Harris which by the way I have an
episode coming out tonight right after
this ends called Sam Harris has lost his
mind uh because he has if if he he can't
deal with the fact that he was so
catastrophically wrong on on something
and he's a person that values his
rationality at the highest level this is
why he thinks of religious people as
being such Rubes right because he's so
rational and God is not a rational thing
because it requires Faith but he is so
deeply irrational and he is so clearly
following down a religious line of
thinking when it comes to the covet
hysteria and he can't come to terms with
it and it's tragic honestly do you so
you think we should be uh like carving
out a path path of redemption for
someone like Sam Harrison I'd even go as
far as to say uh this is like I guess
cold hearted but even like Jordan
Peterson like he said I feel like we've
like these these people have been very
important especially in the lives of
young men and they've kind of LED them
down a path like a Jordan Peterson with
the the vax vaccines and some of the
other things he said and I'm just kind
of like I'm not ready to discard you but
I'm ready I I've been ignoring you for a
while I just don't know what to do with
these with so we got people there's got
to be a path of redemption otherwise
people will just go the other direction
but how about if you don't say come to
me they'll walk away from you yes Sam
doesn't want Redemption do you think
that there's more people coming up
though like there's more perspective uh
there's more prospects in in our Horizon
that probably have something to say
maybe maybe better or maybe equal to
what these guys have said let me let me
put it this way you're on a battlefield
and you got red on one side blue on the
other let's let's say green and yellow
we don't want to make a red and blue and
you're on the green side and a yellow
dude with his hands up drops his weapon
and starts walking towards you and he's
or waving a white flag
what do you say do you shoot them do you
like you no no you say bring them in do
you give him access to your secret
documents no but you say
thank you for coming over perhaps I
worded it incorrect not not that there
shouldn't be a path for Redemption but
obviously we're like okay you know you
kind of messed up here uh Jordan which I
named my whole brand after you because
it was you know I looked up to the guy
um but some of the top Lobster top
Lobster Lobster yeah there you go uh
some of the things I think he's said and
done are almost unforgivable especially
in this landscape and it it's tough to
be correct all the time but I don't know
we got guys like this Smith were pretty
correct I try to correct your wrongs I
mean I think Ben Shapiro should have
done that I think Jordan Peterson should
have done that they all promoted yes the
the product the the you know the shot
and we needed a bigger conversation here
so if we're gonna hold Sam Harris
critical of it like we got to hold other
people so if you if look it's it's
really simple we want as many people to
be like let's let's say you got 10
people over here saying you know Bach
and you got 10 people are saying bark
you want as many people as possible
saying bark I don't care if it said buck
10 10 minutes go come over here and you
know say the thing that works for us but
we do got to go to super chats because I
don't wanna I don't want to go too long
sure but I'm just saying like
you have to even if it pains you it's
how you win oh I believe I believe
there's always a path of redemption but
do they want it and I think Jordan
Peterson probably does Sam Harris not so
much we're going to Super Jazz but I
want to I want to add one thing that uh
and I'll tell you what we're doing
look we've got a bunch of shows we're
making
and they make some money and we want
them to be successful on their own and
we want to cultivate talent and
personalities because the idea
ultimately is it's a very simple
mathematic formula
why do I want to build everything in
West Virginia because there's good
people in West Virginia's Maga country
if these people in West Virginia who
live in Maga country who believe in
individual liberty freedom and fly the
Gadsden flag had access to more money
they would invest in more products they
would invest in businesses that support
their values they would build businesses
that support these values so when you
guys give money to timcast and we opened
a coffee shop in West Virginia and we
hire people in West Virginia and we
build industry in West Virginia it is
Maga country that sees their revenues
increasing and if I get one dollar and I
hand that dollar to Jim Bob Jim Bob gets
that dollar of course the government's
taken their cut every step of the way of
course you know we're offensive but then
Jim Bob has that dollar and he says okay
now I can give it to Mary Sue Mary Sue
gets that dollar now she says now I can
buy the thing I need it starts building
up the economy and the resources of
individuals with better ideas that's
trickle down that you know I'm not
saying it's like oh I've got money I'm
saying it spreads out and ripples
empowering people with better ideas
that's the whole point so we're
launching this coffee company very very
soon
and uh get after it yeah we're gonna do
coffee shops physical locations we're
going to create uh we're gonna do
subscription base so you can sign up to
automatically get your bag of coffee
weekly by weekly or however much you
want you can just be like set it up
that's the best way to do it and uh I'm
I I really don't want to say this just
yet because it may be unfair and um but
I but I've sent out the message I'm
really hoping that with our our coffee
company and and we're selling these
subscription coffee companies I'm really
hoping that Cal Rittenhouse is willing
to to work with us in some capacity you
know maybe maybe wear our shirt or
something like that because we're big
fans shots fired we believe in in
Liberty and Justice and uh you know I'm
definitely willing to support this young
man but I'll tell you why I'm saying it
one the one reason I didn't want to say
it is because it's his business it's his
life and there's a controversy around
that but I had a conversation with this
kid and
what does he do you know what I mean
what can he do and so when I'm like I'm
sitting here thinking like man I feel
bad for this kid because how could he be
a nurse you know he walks into a he
walks the the left is attacking him he
walks into a room with a guy who's
injured and like here's your nurse
caught right now is that something he
told me that was there when he told you
that was funny and I'm like wow like
they really destroyed this kid's life
yeah dude and I'm like okay maybe
there's an opportunity there maybe maybe
there's some in some way he can work
with our coffee company because we're
willing to you know we believe in him
but uh let's read super chance let's
read because we're going late I just
want to say if you do franchise your
coffee company let us let us know
Florida Florida Tim cash coffee
Florida's also Magica whatever it's
called you know yeah yeah hot coffee is
that a brand yet I promise it's not
gonna start my own h-a-w-t yeah I'm
thinking the idea is to have like a like
some kind of private club component to
it yeah where it's like you pay a
monthly you know like we've talked about
doing a legitimate Social Club 501c7
where it's like five grand a year but
maybe it's just like 10 bucks a month
and you can go ahead hangout Ian's
Crystal Cove you know and then we make
like a little hangout space where people
can have coffee or something dude I'm
gonna meditate in that Cove I'm already
in charge of crystals yeah
we gotta read the super jets and I'll
just say yeah we didn't talk about
anything but the Stephen Crowder in the
media land yeah because like I don't
know I just it's it's it's so important
it's so important I thought it was a
good conversation anyways Deborah
mcstash is hey Tim hope you're feeling
better now missed you today wasn't the
same P.S the late mima's throat remedy
hot water honey lemon juice and ground
clove gargle and spit don't swallow
should help and then you gotta not eat
I've done everything the big challenges
don't eat anything there's one actual
remedy there's one literal remedy and
it's NSAIDs
ibuprofen naproxen or if you can afford
it Toradol but you'll need a metal
partition I think for total
um losing your voice is caused by
inflammation in the throat NSAIDs reduce
the inflammation allowing you to speak I
think they do cortisol injections for
celebrity singers who have to do a show
and they lose their voice and then you
get your voice back
but it's really really good to do dip
your hands in some aloe and then stick
it down your throat and rub it around on
the vocal cords Jesus Christ it's a
little invasive but it works no no you
just you override your gag reflex I've
been training for this my whole life
Steven says Tim needs to rest his voice
I'm not paying 10 bucks a month for him
to destroy himself
yeah that's a great thank you for saying
that it is a good point that's kind of
what happened to Jordan Peterson man he
he overworked himself and then ended up
in rehab just stay off the painkillers
well he he took a lot of drugs yes they
had Pharma drugs that he should have
been critical of yesterday I took four
ibuprofen so that's how it starts I
could work in the morning after about an
hour and a half my voice worked enough
but it was still rough and then by like
five
took some more and was able to do the
nightly show but it was still kind of
rough this morning at my limit if if you
take too much your your stomach stops
producing the mucous lining you get
ulcers right and it starts hurting
before the show started Tim said uh you
know what there's a lot of guys here so
you guys kind of take a conversation now
oh yeah and then he had a lot to say the
Crowder thing is too is too big
especially like yeah this is the fight
though like the platforming issues that
we're dealing with the censorship we
didn't even mention the Twitter leaks
and how we have now hard evidence that
you have the FBI CIA all these people
that are involved in setting the terms
of service I mean this is a really
important conversation so I've been
working on the charity for this
technology that can help Steven for two
years we're still we're still on filing
but I mean this is serendipitous takes
like two years that was the only reason
we started it in the beginning creating
an easy way that anyone can spin up
their own membership website oh that's
beautiful so that there is no more
Network there's no more I get five
percent there's no more I get twenty
percent and it creates a network of all
the people that are using the software
so like oh that's really cool yep and so
that way you create a network where no
one can be banned where nobody is is a
boss over them but you can still
discover content Let's uh let's read
more Cosmic surgeon says Tim please name
names someone has to be the one to stop
protecting these people truth is an
absolute defense of libel I will tell
you uh I know I know a whole lot about
what's going on
but not naming names it's because
I don't I don't see bad guys in this
story
you got you know two guys are fighting
over who owns a piece of land one guy
says my grandfather is the one who came
and cleared the bush out of here and
made it livable and then this dude came
in and lived here and he goes what do
you mean he cleared some Bush but there
were wolves all over the place it was my
dad who came in and got rid of the
wolves and now they're arguing over who
owns the land and I'm like these guys
aren't evil people they're making
they're staying they're staking their
claim and we're trying to adjudicate
fairly who really is the person who's in
the right who's really in the wrong
Crowder thinks these contracts are bad I
agree but I don't think the company
that's offered them up is doing it
because they're evil and they're doing
it because they're looking at their
terms and being like yo if this guy gets
a strike we lose all this money we're
screwed it's a highly competitive space
yeah and even with me getting screwed
over at the end of the day they have
their own different side and version of
their story but I'm happy that it
happened and I'm grateful for it now
right Jason Dixon says Tim I'm a member
for two years six months and 23 days I
will move my ten dollars to 10 timcast
website and drop YouTube thoughts
absolutely
you are you are much better off this is
so
here's here's the way it works for us
because I just tell you guys
YouTube's got rules we break them we get
shut down so what do we do we talk about
what we can here and then we say the
speakeasies round back
timcast.com uncensored become a member
and there's a big library of all the
uncensored conversations for the most
part our opinions don't really we're not
like masking our opinions we just
we avoid saying things in certain ways
like swearing we swear a lot on the
members only but like certain subjects
just get put there right for safety
reasons yeah there's an option because a
lot of people are like have balls and
just say it on YouTube it's like oh then
we cease to exist that's stupid yeah I
don't I don't like right now if we're on
YouTube the central Battlefield and
we've got a bridge leading to the
Speakeasy where people can talk it's
better than just nuking you got to keep
that bridge open man it sucks you know
well as long as you can at least yeah
yeah but become a member of teamcast.com
uh or not look man I don't know you know
there's a lot of people who
you know every day I see people saying
stuff like
just discouraging things you know you
shouldn't be doing this you shut down
you know Tim pool only cares about money
Tim pool only cares about Fame and it's
those those are the kind of people that
make me feel like you know maybe I
should not be trying to fight for these
people and then I'm like but I always
know those are not real fans those are
not real Fighters those are the people
trying to trick you that's the devil on
your shoulder telling you they have your
best interest at heart but they're
really trying to sabotage everything
that that's the Jordan Peterson uh where
he gets it right there's the people that
have you know just gone too far down the
black black build path that they start
lashing out yeah is it really important
for Noah Sanders he says wait didn't you
all have Steve Hilton from Fox on as a
guest how'd y'all swing getting him in
if fox has you all blacklisted keep up
the great work we talked to him about
this actually and he was like afterwards
he was like we were like how did they
allow you to come on he's like what do
you mean and we were like Fox guests
can't come on this show and he goes I
didn't tell him he's like I didn't read
my contract it's amazing yeah I'm in
trouble
yeah
Fareed Mahood says let me guess daily
wire trying to shaft Crowder have helped
people in the past get signed with with
DW and their contracts are just as bad
as the rest of media I wouldn't be
surprised but uh I don't know
you know
I'm actually surprised Crowder came out
and and complained about the contract
because you know most people would just
be like if you if like when they offered
me a deal I didn't go public and just be
like you know here's what I'm being
offered from these different companies
I'm like look if you come to me and say
you'll give me 10 bucks to quit the show
and go work at McDonald's I'll say no
but you don't I don't owe you anything
you owe me anything I'm not going to
come out and be like how dare you I'm
but I think what Crowder did why I think
it was good is because we got to change
this landscape yeah I don't think
I mean it is tough because I do Wonder
would the personalities that daily wire
exist in this capacity without the daily
wire
you know what I mean well Jordan
Peterson would it's like the well Woody
though he's doing a lot more stuff
nowadays with the daily wire than he was
before well I think that's also because
he's just finally getting his mind right
it's kind of like the story of like I
guess the founding of this nation so
like if this nation didn't accrue a ton
of debt in order to like to recover from
the the Revolutionary War would we be
where we are at now I don't know
interesting so it's kind of like you
know what would the daily wire have that
many you know content creators if they
didn't do that it's hard to say
Fareed says Tim quote I don't care about
money and want to help people pool not
gonna lie you're sounding like SPF with
FTX I I'm also sounding a whole lot like
Disney I'm studying a whole lot like
Netflix and NASCAR and any other ESG
company that's like we have to put
diversity Equity inclusion at the core
of our business because the stakeholders
matter and profit isn't everything me I
completely agree we got to put the
Gadsden flag on all the properties and
molon labe because the values are are
what matters and the money is secondary
if we can afford to eat and we can
afford to expand then afterwards we
invest in making this country a better
place period because you know what if
you don't
don't put that money yeah but I'll make
it simple for everybody I am investing
my money in America
if I don't I will owe nothing and be
very unhappy
shout out to Klaus that's right so these
people who are like you know I'll just
make the money and then go disappear I'm
like you're not gonna have money in Five
Years bro yeah well if you do it ain't
gonna buy much I bought Tesla stock
recently because California Oregon and
Washington are Banning gas cars
you know and a lot of people talk about
the fear of electric cars in the central
centralization control I'm like yet it's
the smart grid not necessarily the
electric group it's a component for sure
they can turn off your power and then
what do you do and I'll build a solar
device I'll figure it out
all right
ghost Crusaders Tim you know the smear
Merchants are going to write hit piece
after hit piece on you even harder now
that you revealed how much you make
annually yeah I gave a general estimate
the funny thing is on my Wikipedia page
like it includes an estimate of our
monthly income and I'm just like that's
so weird it's so weird they would do
that The Daily Beast wrote a hit piece
and they included a fake number about
our revenue and I was like why I talked
to him I was like that's not that's not
a real number like why are you including
it and they're like well we heard and
I'm like about a year and a half ago I
got doxed and someone had like Googled
my name and discovered my old company
name and online they found that I had
six employees which I didn't and that I
was only grossing or netting I forget 50
Grand a year and they posted that to try
and like demonstrate that I was I was a
fraud as opposed to just realizing that
this information is completely nonsense
I had six employees and I was I was
grossing 50 Grand a year do you
understand how criminal that would be
man so like a robber baron dude
there's a good one uh Justin swordahl
says my mug club sub was a hundred
dollars annually if half of Crowder's
Subs paid that's 300 million dollars
annually 200 million for three years is
trash it's not about the money you're
right except
three million people will never
subscribe
Crowder can get you know uh he's got I
think on this video since it went up
let's say 300 000 views I guarantee
not 99 percent
like of of those people who watched
because of the subject matter of the
video
I'd say two percent maybe signed up yeah
mug Club in merchandising it's about a
three percent retention rate when people
like view your product so it's probably
way less for this oh it's definitely
less I mean look we if if we've got 1.4
million Subs on this channel holy crap
if 700 000 people were paying 10 bucks a
month we would be doing a lot more than
we are we I would I would build a small
City No No Junk this is a crazy thing
like we're building this new building
the new building we're putting up is 40
foot 40 feet tall in the middle 25 foot
walls with a studio built inside and the
whole thing's gonna cost around half a
million dollars and then we got to do
the skate components and the
entertainment stuff it's gonna be
another couple hundred thousand dollars
dude if we had half of our viewers
because we get a collective like 60
million hits per month that would be 84
million annually if we had but we get uh
like on this video right now there's 39
000 people currently watching it peaked
at like 45. if every one of these people
signed up
wow but they don't they don't have to
I'm not telling you you have to I'm just
saying like the conversion rate ain't
there yeah no it's not like man I know
you know if if
10 of uh
if if we had 140 000 people giving us 10
bucks a month could you imagine if 10
well see this is where I think the
network play actually works because like
on gas digital you have 12 different
programs that once you pay you get all
of this uncensored content whereas if
you're one Creator well you just don't
have enough content to offer to like
really justify that expenditure so
that's where I think the network play
does make sense for the the person to
subscribe if you're if if you're a
Channel with like 100 000 subs and
someone comes to you and says we got 10
channels each of the hundred thousand
subs and we're creating a network and
we're going to sell it for 10 bucks a
month and we'll pay you a hundred
thousand dollars a year right it might
make it might be worth it to you I know
a lot of people are signing deals with
Rumble because rumble's like we're going
to give you money and they're like wow I
can pay my bills now yeah that's great
Kim Iverson actually bless her heart we
become friends over the past year I was
just on her new Rumble exclusive show
and I told her after my second strike I
was like look I don't know what I'm
gonna do but I know you got the
exclusive deal with Rumble can you help
liberty lockdown become a rumble
exclusive and she said she's going to
ask so let's see I mean like it's tragic
that this is the game that we're in
where we're just constantly ducking and
dodging and trying to get uh different
platforms to to Keep Us Alive but yeah
nature of the Beast I've thought that
you were supposed to be vocal about what
you believed that was what I thought
growing up well the one I did in 2006
and I haven't stopped really except the
sensors I'm trying to be kind you naive
little guy I'm gonna read a regular
trying to tell the truth I got a regular
chat that needs to be read uh was this
uh lulls Sanchez says I pay for mug Club
only for Crowder
pretty sure
mug Club was just a blaze membership am
I wrong about that I really don't know
so like I thought it like originated
from I guess changed my mind things but
I'm not really sure I don't know I don't
know exactly but I thought when Crowders
with the blaze if you sign up for mug
Club you were signing up for The Blaze
like otherwise I don't understand how
that would make sense I thought it began
when it was just him as a solo operator
but maybe he was always part of the
blaze I really don't know didn't like
Ben Shapiro before the daily wire was a
huge operation he had the like the
liberal mugs liberal tear mugs like what
was that liberal tears I've seen that
yeah did people just sign up and they
got a mug like what what else did they
get I don't I don't really know oh so
the daily wire gain control of Shapiro's
merch when he when they kind of formed
all the merch that he'd Built pre-wire
Well what was he offering like back
before there was this whole daily wire
Incorporated thing
a lot of I don't know a lot of questions
I know he and Jeremy kind of created the
thing together with the third guy Caleb
I believe his name I don't know Caleb
yamabushi Nate says Tim no offense but
on your comment on your crew I really
like Luke and serge and Ian it makes the
show for me well I'll clarify you're not
saying anything bad about them it's so
weird that people are hearing well well
you know just to add contacts for one
Loop has never worked here because Luke
owns his own media company so he's his
own dude like his own company of profits
um but as for what I was saying is
Tim cast iron couldn't exist without the
employees who work for the show
but if I didn't do this show I would
still be well off doing just Tim cast
news and Tim guest
and it's like the amount of the it's
it's a diminishing return yeah the
amount of money I make
from working like if if I only worked
one hour the bulk of my money would come
in I had a second hour I make less I
made a third hour even less and so like
the 16th hour of work I do brings in
very little money yes exactly I bet
though because it's all subscription-bit
or a lot of it's absorption based you're
almost at the point where you could work
seven to eleven every day just do this
show and you still make the same amount
of subscriptions
I mean IRL drives almost all the
subscriptions like I think the
overwhelming majority of memberships for
timcast.com is just this show well a
perfect example I ran a mortgage company
I made a half a million dollars a year
working by myself and I just subbed out
all of the work for loan docs and title
and everything else I could have brought
in employees because I was a broker they
could have worked under me I could have
made points off of them they could have
all made a good living of 150 to 200 000
a year I would have increased my annual
net revenue probably 50 to 100 000 per
employee I bought on brought on but my
quality of life would have been so
catastrophically diminished I opted not
to that doesn't mean that those people
aren't valuable that means that I am
making a different decision for myself
that doesn't mean that I I despise or
think that those people are worthless
I'm just making a different Choice Tim
went the other route and he's now
growing a real you know powerful thing
that like a real real Network Enterprise
here and I just didn't I'm just I don't
have that in me I don't want to go that
route it has a lot of work I probably
won't do it today though because now I
understand how dire things are but back
when I was doing that it didn't seem
like we were so close to the precipice
the the first couple of years when we
launched this I was working with no days
off so I would do Sunday to Sunday you
know Monday to Sunday the temple Morning
Show six segments between timcast news
and Tim cast on YouTube and the podcast
and then Monday through Friday at you
know 8 10 past IRL and then
um I think 2020 and if and I think in uh
2021 is when I stopped New Year of 2021
I stopped working weekends and I removed
three segments I brought those three
segments back but I'm still not working
weekends the issue was that I literally
had no time to go to the bank and I was
like okay I'm doing a lot of content
makes a lot of money but if I don't go
to the bank here's the crazy thing too
doing the podcast every day with no days
off put the Tim pool Daily Show in like
the top 30 podcasts in the world because
it guaranteed me above everybody else
because people stop stop worrying once I
stopped working Temple Daily Show fell
completely off the charts and it's like
300 or something
all right A lot of people are saying we
didn't watch the video Crowder put out I
watched the entire thing Chase said Tim
it's not about the money in Steven's
contract it's about the mechanisms to
control his speech y'all are missing the
point Stephen is saying that big
conservative is watering down the
message of its creators through the
deals
I think he misunderstands I think
the contract was bad but I think it was
an issue of hammering out the details I
don't see these companies as evil I see
them as needing to exist but I think
these deals don't work this way anymore
and the system can't survive this way
anymore I think
what he was seeing was them saying if
you get a strike we are going to remove
X from the guarantee because you can't
make money for us but I think the
percentages they put were ridiculous
like that just clearly didn't work and I
I don't know like all right so here's
the deal I I think that Crowder has a
point I think that there's also a bigger
point about whether or not there is
controlled opposition that exists in the
conservative realm and I don't think
that daily wire or the blaze or any of
these people are necessarily in that
category but I do think that it's
interesting to if we could unwind the
finances that go into these deals you
know the the actual like Source funding
that creates these networks and then
understand why these contracts are being
structured how they are that would tell
you perhaps whether or not this was
actually a mechanism for trying to
control a counter narrative position
sure yeah YouTube is actually just
alphabet the company you can call it
whatever you want it's got a skin suit
on that says the word you tube on it but
it's alphabet so like who really is
running the show exactly all right Pat
Meadows says if Tim cast negotiates a
contract with and with Crowder and gets
him on board I will triple my monthly
membership payment to timcast who's with
me let's take a poll how many people pay
30 bucks a month to see get a Tim Tim
pool store if a million of you sign up
tonight I think it'll happen if 20 bucks
a month is doable I mean that could
happen tomorrow and no one would lose a
thing let me let me let me let me let me
just you know I normally don't like to
talk about private business but let me
tell you guys something I I talked to
Crowder periodically and I did make him
an offer I did
yeah and you know what he said
he said no did he crap on your contract
you know what the contract offer was it
was I don't see how how we could work
with you in any kind of capacity like
this the conversation wasn't explicitly
about what's going on with this we were
like having a conversation in general
and then I was like you're way too big
for us to like ever work with you in any
kind of capacity like that but here's
here's my offer uh I know some guys who
can build your own website and we can
probably like arrange a way that you can
have your own independent thing I can
connect you with them that was the deal
that was the offer and he was like well
I can probably find a company I'll
figure something I was like okay cool
man like good luck like I don't I I told
him I was like bro like
we're doing our thing here and I was
like
you gotta Like You Gotta Do Your Own
Thing Man it's the only way we get
through this and you know and we've
we've we've like we've talked about a
bunch of stuff just privately as I guess
friends or whatever you call I I never
hung out with him in person but uh you
know we've talked about like a lot of
political stuff and I was we were
talking generally again not about this
we were talking about you know something
unrelated and I mentioned like you know
in the culture war with Disney and stuff
like people got to do their own thing
man I was like you got to do your own
thing and so my my my whole point was
like
the only way we win is when you have
your own thing going it just wouldn't
make sense otherwise I don't know how
anyone can sign deals with these big
companies like this does that make sense
well given the nature of that particular
contract I understand why people don't
yeah my thing's just like if you're as
big as Crowder like
you gotta own your own thing that's the
only thing you can do
but yeah I was talking to him and I was
like what's your what's the deal with
their website like you know I know a guy
give his number good luck he needs help
getting a website yeah yeah I mean I
don't know Wix he didn't show you the
web link that's a point like he didn't
need anything for me he's doing
everything already kind of amazing I'm
willing to bet he starts pulling in like
10 15 million per month oh media I
wouldn't I wouldn't be surprised if
Crowder surpasses the daily wire in a
few years wow interesting yeah
absolutely it really comes down to this
you want to manage it because what they
do with the daily wire is great is that
the three of them Ben Jeremy and as a
Caleb I should I want to make sure I get
his name right I don't know him
personally they run it I mean Ben
actually is hands off he's doing the
Crowder role with daily wire Jeremy's
taking care of the business so Crowder
would need a guy like Jeremy to take
care of this thing is Jeremy owns half
the company or a third third of the
company or something so you give that up
for that do you think because of uh
because of like the comedy role the
Crowder Crowder plays why he would
surpass the daily wire why do you think
that he's got he's the he's like the
biggest personality
yeah but does that I mean how does that
exactly correlate is it is I mean the
content is what I'm talking about why is
it you're looking you look at what
Crowder's doing right now he's a culture
Warrior right is I don't think the daily
wire are like to the same degree and the
people subscribe to the Daily wire for
good kind I mean Jordan Peterson's a
good guy to watch it's great he's a
culture Warrior Ben Shapiro is to a
certain degree but Paterson Stephen
Crowder well I think it's because of
this is why we have the two platforms
and Tower gang is for the comedic Outlet
I think that you can reach people that
you simply cannot reach if you don't go
comedy route you know
um I'm really inspired by Black Rifle
coffee those guys are really awesome
seriously because I know some stuff
I don't know what I can and can't say
but I've I remember learning about the
people they've signed deals with
and I was shocked to learn that high
profile mainstream athletes were signing
with Black Rifle and I'm like this is
the greatest thing I've ever heard
because black rifles staunchly pro-gun
and conservative and you got mainstream
top-tier Action Sports athletes signing
deals with them
like wow
but why did they not
get on board with defending Kyle
Rittenhouse outright the response to
Kyle Rittenhouse was
we do not sponsor Kyle right now saying
we will not sponsor Kyle right now they
said we do not profit off of tragedy and
we you know we we not do not intend to
be involved in this and I'm just kind of
like
as weird to me you're a guns rights
company you can't you can't fail in that
moment no matter no matter the media
heat that comes you cannot fail and they
did and my and my attitude was like
if we started a coffee company like we
are and one day Kyle Rittenhouse wore
our shirt my statement would explicitly
be we are honored that this young man
was wearing the shirt of our company
thank you Kyle Rittenhouse God bless
promo code Kyle well I mean that's up to
up to Kyle but my point is just this
like
this is why I think
Stephen Crowder will do better than the
daily wire because Stephen Crowder is
the guy who will walk up into the face
of the machine and say F you no it's
challenging though because Crowders like
it's like comparing a warrior to an
armada of ships like each like Crowder's
one ship in the Armada that is the daily
wire and so and I just want to take this
moment to say how much I love your brain
thanks homie you just come with that
analogy out of nowhere you kidding me I
was thinking about like 30 seconds this
is genius stuff people are sleeping on
me in Crossland you better it's my
favorite cast member no I A lot of
people are saying F BRC I'm like I
disagree man like Black Rifle coffee is
extremely important uh I don't know
which athletes I'm allowed to say have
signed deals with them because I don't
know which ones what public or not but
this is a tremendously positive thing in
cultural takeover
and I get the game they're playing I
think they're you know the daily wire to
our coffee our coffee company
is going to be like
yeah we're not going to screw around
we're not going to play dirty games
we're not going to be crazy a-holes or
anything we're just going to be like if
someone comes and get a journalist
they're going to be like you you know
you Kyle right now she's wearing your
shirt and I'll be like that's cool yes
and yeah yes and a lot of people wear
our shirts we think Kyle writtenhouse
was unjustly well unjustly prosecuted I
think it was a clear-cut case of
self-defense and we are glad to see that
Justice prevailed in this case he was
acquitted yeah having his life was also
ruined by the media so I don't respect
any of your questioning how about that
yeah like I don't understand why like
Black Rifle no I get it I guess they're
trying to go mainstream they're trying
to be more mainstream similar to
sometimes when we adhere to the sensors
on YouTube we'll end up people be like
why why don't you just say it you're
like well we're
following the sensorial rules that we
don't necessarily agree with because we
want to stay on YouTube maybe they
thought they'd get blacklisted if they
went bullish unconscious
like that's more of an idealist like
different like Wheels between you guys
we go in the members only show and we
outright just talk about these subjects
we don't say well no hold on you know
like the daily wire does it does an
important thing
and I think crowdedly bigger than them
because Crowder is is more trumpian in
that regard we're a bit over so sure we
got to go to the members only but I
could talk about this kind of stuff for
a million years
so uh all right we'll I'll read this
last one Alan Hale says Tim please Puck
that pluck that singular white hair from
your beard it's bothering me there's one
right here where is it I don't know
right on the bottom right did a little
more of those yeah and then sell it sell
it on the website nft this was like man
we have so much news to talk about we
didn't because like this is this is the
the the how the sausage gets made yeah
really really important conversation but
let's talk more in the members only
section about a lot of stuff so head
over to timcast.com become a member to
support our work directly let me read
this one from John Bartholomew he says
Black Rifle is not pro-gun Tim research
their statements positions and political
donations all right well mark my words
we're launching a company I don't know
if I can say the name just yet because
we're still designing everything we've
got the graphics ready to go I think
we're we're waiting on the bags to get
printed and we've tested the Blends out
I like a mean dark roast but we've also
got a nice bright blend called rise with
Roberto Jr and I I could go either way
um We're Not Gonna hide you know look
the company's not going to make
political donations I really don't
understand why why the company would
donate to packs but um if we do we will
give to uh good guns rights
organizations and politicians not that
the company is a gun company or anything
like that but uh I will say it like if
God like I I would be honored if we
could have Kyle right now in some
capacity wear our shirt or do something
like that I got no I like black rival
coffee but we're going to be more
aggressive in our culture Warrior
Warrior ready do you think that Black
Rifle nailed kind of like when they were
throwing the dildos at the wall on the
vice documentary they're like if we can
talk about transgenderism and racism
like they have rifles and coffee in
their title so they brought are we
missing something I had nothing to do
with 2A or anything yeah what let's uh
let's let's we'll go to the members only
show saw so smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the
shows with your friends this was really
a lot of inside baseball but I
appreciate everybody sticking around and
listening to this very esoteric episode
shout out to Stephen Crowder
um I think it's really important to call
out how this machine works as we start
to change the shape of it and um I don't
think there's any bad guys here I just
think it's a it's an archaic machine
that needs to change and I think Crowder
is going to take over the space I really
do so I'm a big fan and I'm really
excited to see what happens so I'll head
over to timcast.com become a member you
can follow the show at timcast IRL you
can follow me at timcast Tower gang guys
you want to shout anything out
uh just at Liberty lockpaw on Twitter
got 65ku over there that's one of the
platforms I'm not afraid of losing uh
please go subscribe to liberty lockdown
on Rumble and also Tower gang on Rumble
and uh last but not least Liberty
lockdown.locals.com also very final note
mises [ __ ] is putting together a debate
between Dave Smith and Destiny live in
Tennessee and right now the B team if
you will would be Clint Russell versus
Bosch and Bosch The Gauntlet has been
thrown I challenge you sir when is that
yeah that sounds awesome he has not uh
this is why I want to take the
opportunity but you say it's already
confirmed it's gonna be Dave Smith and
Destiny well that's what the mises
caucus is telling me they have I love
that I've been watching a lot of Destiny
content Steve and I just went back and I
watched Bosch on here uh against who was
it I don't know great to be Charlie Kirk
they're all talking about such important
stuff very impressive man oh yes uh you
can follow me at top Lobster with an a
uh toplopsa.com go to to
podcastsmarts.com and I also want to
just shout out the people that I do work
for like hotep Jesus Majid Nawaz uh Josh
Smith would break the cycle no way Jose
liberty lockdown recovered all these
Naturals capitalists and and uh yeah
shout out to God he's like a brother to
me
and check out Tower gang thank you guys
maybe with we are changed soon we'll
talk anyway uh my website is Luke
uncensored.com you made a very important
Point uh to telling people to
specifically vote with their dollar I've
been working my butt off for many years
now building up Lucan sensor.com I do a
lot of videos on there a lot of amas a
lot of giveaways a lot of meetups a lot
of merchandise You Name It We got it all
look uncensored.com see you there lots
of crazy news they're bringing in all
the prostitutes to Davos lots of
craziness to talk about uh we're gonna
get into that in this after show I
talked about it too so uh thanks for
having me always a pleasure to see you
guys always a pleasure to host a show
for you guys out there listening thank
you so much for coming listening hit the
like button on your way out if you
haven't done that yet and consider
subscribing to timcast.com I think you
did a poll yesterday honestly 24 of the
people watching had been subscribed I
was shocked a lot yeah a few more more
let's get behind the scenes and see
what's going on ah love you and you can
follow me at Ian crossland.net if you
wanna catch you later hey guys love you
too I love the show uh it's been great
um I don't feel any animosity towards
him for hiring me and giving me a job to
be able to work here and do all these
things poor victim you yeah seriously I
mean he brought me out of Hollywood he
brought me out of the the belly of the
Beast so to speak uh I'm always grateful
I love this show I like me I've been a
fan of the show since the beginning I
love this I love this program I love the
platform we're doing a good thing here I
left being in like this totally
different world to be able to be here
and do what I believe in like Tim said
it's an ideological company you have to
support the idea and what we're all
standing behind here so
smash that like button like uh like Ian
said and uh let's roll the after show
yeah I think uh you know if we do get
into more of the media stuff all in the
members show I'll try to uh just spill
the beans as much as I can on as much as
I can what I try to avoid doing is just
stepping on the toes of people who've
not wronged me and have not wronged
others just because two people have a
civil dispute doesn't mean either of
them are bad guys but I'll I'll try and
talk about as much as I can with with
the money and the deals and like what
we're working on and why we're working
on it you know there's there's potential
risks I have people saying like don't
talk about money someone mentioned like
Oh no you're gonna hit pieces because
you mentioned like revenue streams and
stuff and I'm like yeah I don't know I'm
like I don't know maybe people just
deserve to know exactly what's going on
and why it's going on and they can make
their choice their informed choices
based on that so let's talk we'll talk
about some numbers and maybe maybe the
media will run head pieces head over to
timcast.com become a member if you want
to hear this and uh we'll see you all
over there cheers